But it's like it immediately becomes obvious that that's exactly
what's going on is they're just trying to menace Dan or Yeah,
they're just trying to menace him. Okay. Jason Thor Hall's long
history of abusing report buttons.
There is a big drama kind of brewing around how he's like whining
about how people just don't understand that like I I don't even
think that platforms should be the only people moderating content
on their platforms. Like okay, shut the [__] up,
bro. Pirate Software banning a chatter that stated that one of
the ferrets in the rescue died due to a lack of mana. I'm pretty
sure this happened back when the actual WOW stuff happened. Banning
somebody is awesome. Banning somebody from the chat always feels
good. Okay, it never feels bad. He has acted in a completely
insane way over and over and over again until people There's
no way this is a person. There's no way this is a human being.
Come on. They don't have opinions. Is this supposed to mean?
He was basically like, "Oh, did you see Dan tried to dox this
guy?" And I read the post. I'm like, "Dude, it looks like this
guy's like basically menacing Dan with like listings in Miami
Beach or some
I'm pretty sure that's the case." Anyway, next.
Guess where we're going next, guys?
Our
our favorite brother down under. Okay, we got a card posting
video. Okay. Jason Thor Hall's long history of abusing report
buttons.
I told Kelly she didn't want to be here. I knew she wouldn't
want to be here cuz we've got Card Tent today. Okay, we've got
Card Tent. Jason Thorhal's long history of abusing report buttons.
So, there is a big drama kind of brewing around. I saw him respond
to this. I saw Pirate Software respond to this. How he's like
whining about how people just don't understand that like I I
don't even think that platforms should be the only people moderating
content on their platform. It's like, okay, shut the up, bro.
All right. Okay, I got my contact. I need water and then I will
be right back. Water bathroom. Right back. But I'm going to hit
play on this guy. We're going to let card take us into the start
of the stream. We're going to go through this. We're going to
go through a little bit more of the
the coding stuff and then there's like some new stuff today as
well. Okay, it's basically like Pirate Software. So, I feel a
little bad for him. Okay, because today there's a post at the
top of LSF. pirates after cheated on his partner
uh for somebody who for a heartbound donator at TwitchCon or
something and I was like oh that's uh that's the not Lykan um
oh but that's the the furry right we read all the DMs that's
them uh li
that's Lyric wolf yes that's the lyric wolf person who cheated
with him and it's like dude all of his old controversies just
keep coming up and they're like the top thing on LSF people like
talk about it gets deleted and he's just getting cycled over
and over Again, it's really it's actually kind of up. I feel
a little bit bad for him to be honest with you. Not actually
bad, like performatively bad. Normally, I don't do performatively
feeling bad for somebody. I actually feel bad for Pirate Software
in this case. I think he's actually getting like railroaded when
it's like the Lyric Wolf thing again and it's like top of LSF
again. The coding stuff will be funny. Everyone is going to have
input. The coding stuff is okay, right? The coding stuff's all
right. I think people I think the coding Jesus video was not
very good. There is another video that I'm thinking about watching.
There's another video from somebody who like reverse engineers
the code. Oh, it's this one right here. It's this guy. It's this
video. This video got a lot of >> So, how this video got
a lot of views. I might check this one out as well. I don't even
know if I have it. I'll open it up just in case. Okay. So, pir
sorry
card posting video and then we'll go into the other things. But
I'm going to hit play. I'm going to get some water, use the bathroom.
I'll be right back. First things first, download this video right
now. I mean it. Surely you've got some means to save a YouTube
video at your disposal.
Save your own copy of this one right now. The whole thing decent
quality, too. Doesn't matter if you're bored at work and looking
for something to watch on your lunch break or you're a big React
streamer live right now. Download this video. I say this because
I know what this video is about and more importantly, I know.
>> Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
I'm firing this up. I'm going over YTDLP right now because I
like to participate. Okay, why would you just watch content and
there's a call to action. You don't even think about doing it,
right? This guy is saying he needs our help. I'm going over YTDLP
with the URL right here, right now. Boom. Downloading the video
right now. Okay, I'll still be right back. I just realized I
didn't hit play on the video. What am I doing? >> And because
of who it's about, >> there's a very real chance it's going
to mysteriously disappear soon. Maybe even before you're done
watching it in full.
>> So, please download it now just in case, then come back
and watch it. Hopefully, you've done that now. So, let's get
into
You might know who I am, what I do here, but if not, it's not.
>> What you do hopefully know is who Jason for Hall is.
>> 2.4 million subs, streamer, software developer who would
really like you to think he's some sort of voice of authority
about digital security and consumer rights and politics and animal
welfare or because of his two decades experience ostensively
developing but never actually publishing computer
Lots of people, especially recently, have, I would say very correctly,
been criticizing Hall for his outspoken opposition to the Stop
Games initiative and his very apparent narcissistic streak and
how he's been generally very dishonest in his interactions with
other large content creators. Here's the thing, though. Being
really also fake voice, also
just a real jerk to to his like fans and stuff who are in his
guild. Also, I don't know. He's a total piece of [__]
>> not there's a lot of other things. >> Being a
liar and a narcissist and telling people you've been working
on a game that realistically might never come out for 10 years.
>> All these things aren't against the law. They're generally
not even against the terms of service of the platforms like YouTube
Hall primarily promotes himself on. But there's something he
definitely does and does a lot which is expressly not allowed
on this platform.
Something I realized. >> Oh wait, false reports. We haven't
really seen >> also I think he >> in the midst of
all this stop killing game stuff
>> because at the very least on YouTube
falsely maliciously knowingly misusing reporting tools to get
other people's content taken down is meant to be a very big no
no.
It's something that if you do repeatedly is supposed to very
well mean you yourself will be removed from the platform permanently.
And I believe Jason Thor Hall has a long history of doing exactly
this and has surely
crossed any reasonable threshold of how much doing that should
get someone removed from YouTube for the sake of other users.
And that's what I want to address specifically in this video.
I'm going to try and keep this as short as I can today, but this
one video isn't likely the only thing I'll be doing about the
problem of Jason Thorhaul's history of report button abuse. And
if you bear with me for just a little bit here, I'll also explain
what I mean by that and why this video is going to have to be
the way it is.
So, I've been planning to make this video for about a week now.
Ever since I got wind of the fact >> Sorry, I'm getting
like a bunch of DMs. This is fine. tried to take down another
video I did called you should hate pirate software >> and
then you said that you've got a whole bunch of his friends who
are reporting to you from like his
>> I liked it very
YouTube short of mine parodying him with the game Postal 2 taken
down I would argue falsely with a report filed for targeted harassment.
I was going to make a video showing off how he coordinates his
most loyal fans through platforms like Discord to mass flag any
videos he doesn't like. how he almost certainly seems to obsessively
name search himself based off of found my small YouTube page
in the first
>> I think he so he might name search himself. I don't
think he's quite like Techone. I think he's got a lot of fans
who like look him up and like try to figure out where the where
the worst offenders are most of the time. >> And I was
going to show off the report I got emailed from YouTube confirming
they would not be letting that short of mine stay up. Then I
put a post out on my YouTube community tab asking if anyone else
had any similar experiences with Hall. And if they did, would
they mind emailing me their stories, evidence, etc. Maybe so
I could platform those stories. And I actually ended up getting
a lot, many of which all fit the same basic pattern,
close to a dozen. >> He does something wrong. People are
like, "Hey, that seems kind of bad of you." And he was like,
"You're a [__] Actually, actually, I did everything
perfect there. Actually, I did everything perfect there. And
you're a [__] for accusing me of doing something
>> Ended up emailing me. >> Yes. Card looks like
Phoenix.
Many people are saying a link to where it used to be on YouTube.
Here's a screenshot of the takedown notice I got. And I did my
bit to confirm all this was legit and it all checked out as far
as I could tell. A lot of people even sent me uh Google Drive
links and such showing me the videos they made months and months
ago. And none of them seem like serious harassment or copyright
infringement to me. But that's what they're all getting struck
for. If they used clips of Hall at all, even like 20 seconds
out of a live stream of his, they got copyright struck. If they
made fun of Hall at all, they got taken down for harassment.
And typically, these YouTube channels would be ones that made
like a couple videos before and would often have maybe a few
hundred subscribers,
often even less. We've seen a couple of these like the the uh
the hit pieces that get made on him generally
like very much they're not long for this world. I've seen at
least two or three people complain about this where they have
like a hit piece on them and it just gets taken down and they
are like yeah like a thousand subs a thousand sub channel. >> People
showed me screenshots of their YouTube studio panel and would
explain hey I never made a video before but I did put one on
Pirate Software and it got a few thousand views and the next
day it was gone. or hey, I have eight subscribers and did a YouTube
poop edit of the roach out World of Warcraft thing and got instanked
off the platform for it. That sort of thing. So, I figured the
people who contacted me directly
wouldn't be the only people this has happened to, surely. So,
I went digging and I found a lot more people online basically
reporting that this had happened to them, too. That they had
covered Jason Thorhaul or Pirate Software in some negative capacity
and shortly thereafter been hit with a takeown notice. There's
a really huge amount of those stories out there
>> Now, I haven't been able to vet all of them yet myself,
as you might expect, >> but
myself at this >> I thought there'd be new information
in this, but apparently not. Don't worry, a lot of this I'm going
to go through the YouTube drama thread on this as well. We'll
we'll check it out cuz I believe Pirates Offer reacts to this
video in some way. Or maybe he doesn't. >> I think they
are by and large all perfectly believable, frankly. Now, the
main reason I'm making this video right now is because I've already
mentioned that I'd be doing something about Hall since he tried
to strike me.
Well, I wanted to keep my word on that and I didn't want people
to be kept waiting in the dark forever. You'll notice that I
haven't included footage of the man himself in this video. That's
primarily because I suspect if I had any at all, he'd be getting
his drones to swarm that report button already.
>> Yes. sort of illustrates a key problem here. How do
you critique someone with thousands of times a larger audience
than you on a platform where they weaponize that audience? Well,
that got me thinking. And now I'm going to be working on a new
side project for a bit. I'm going to compile as much info as
I can on pirate software, doing false claims to people, verify
it all to the best of my abilities, and then put it all on one
big website, which I'll make. I've made websites before. I know
the process of getting them hosted online and even I mean my
day job as a historical researcher is essentially putting together
big binders full of info on any given topic so that should >> I
feel I can do this properly. >> I think Jason Thorhaul
has >> I have a lot of faith in card. I think he could
do it. >> A history of abusing YouTube's reporting system
both automated and otherwise to silence people who hurt his ego.
I think if you laid out all the evidence he does this in one
place, you'd have more than enough to demonstrate he blatantly
transgresses the rules of this website to such an extent that
if it were known, he himself would be banned. Therefore, I will
compile all of that evidence and I'll let you know when that
website is ready. Until then, goodbye for now and have a lovely
day.
>> Wow.
Wow.
Goodbye for now and have a lovely day. You have a lovely day,
too. Card, you have a lovely day, too. I was just going to check
through some of the comments on this video. I saw this video
posted. I think most people know about this, but I just wanted
to see what the general vibe is in like the YouTube drama subreddit.
Okay, so I I got linked the thread and I figured I'd check it
out and then saw it was a card posting video. Figured I'd check
it out and then read the comments. Amazing. If only he had just
talked to Ross instead of spreading misinformation because he
was too stupid to understand the initiative. And if he had owned
up to his mistake in WoW, all this wouldn't have happened. I
actually think the woow thing was the thing that really blew
it up. Honestly, he could have totally he could have totally
Ross um Ross from SKG. Ross from uh oh, what is it? A cursed
farms. He could have totally that guy and been fine. It would
never have been a problem at all, right? Could have totally that
guy, but then he did the World of Warcraft thing and he screwed
himself completely. My Pirate Software's game sucks, dude. People
are eating up the Pirate Software content on YouTube right now.
It's uh it's pretty crazy. Job history and development hell DRM
analysis and code reviews. I actually I was going to watch these.
I don't know if this will be any good. Vicki like reverse compiles
the game and goes through the source code if I'm not mistaken
because I think okay we can watch through it. Essentially what
happened is Pirate Software in is part of his ARG published the
or part of his game published like a debug build and you can
decompile it into like the actual source code. It basically has
the full source code, right? So you you can go through it. Yeah,
people are making insane bank off of hating him. You can go through
the source code and you can actually see like what he's written.
It's pretty close. It lines up pretty closely. He compares it
to some screenshots from the stream because the big thing is
is the code is not technically open sourced. And so when people
want to go through it, they can only go through screenshots or
like scrolls Pirate Software has done on stream, but this guy
actually went and grabbed like the whole thing and he's looking
through the whole thing. So maybe we maybe take a look at this
real quick.
My
Oh, wait. Also, this came out. Pirate Software claims to never
talk about working at Blizzard. Super cut. Hold on. >> I
was mentioning watching a video that was critiquing you for mentioning
you work at Blizzard so much. I literally never talk about it
when I worked at Blizzard. I did that for Blizzard. Blizzard.
Blizzard. Blizzard. Blizzard. 7 years. Yeah. Blizzard. Blizzard.
I used to work at Blizzard Entertainment. I used to work at Blizzard
Entertainment. Used to work at Blizzard Entertainment. Your red
team specialist for Blizzard Entertainment. And Blizzard. Blizzard.
Blizzard. Blizzard is having worked at Blizzard. Blizzard. Blizzard.
Blizzard. I grew up at Blizzard. Blizzard. Blizzard. Blizzard.
Blizzard. Musty for Blizzard Entertainment. Blizzard. Blizzard.
Blizzard. Blizzard. Yeah. Know I uh I worked at Blizzard back
when I used to work at >> The Funny thing is is I'm not
going to go back and verify that these are all unique instances.
They could actually just be overlapping a whole bunch of them.
Maybe you only said it five times. Who am I to know? Who am I
to say? Blizzard. When I was at Blizzard, for those who don't
understand, like uh I used to work at Blizzard Entertainment.
I know how to do that because I I worked at Blizzard. Example
of this. When I was at Blizzard, how do you know so many things?
I worked at Blizzard for 7 years. I don't think I'm better than
other people. I do think that that it's it's funny cuz you you
can that there's a lot of people that brought that up and it's
like I never said that I was. I think sometimes the things that
I talk about in regards to those types of things is misconstrued
as arrogance or boasting when in reality I'm just trying to give
context. >> So God, this interview is so good. This interview
is so good. >> That is the problem right there. So I want
you to listen to this phrase. This gets misconstrued in as arrogance,
but in reality it's this. That is the most arrogant statement
on the planet. Bro, >> I actually am the first second generation
Blizzard. >> My view of reality overpowers your view of
reality. >> I was the first second generation Blizzard
employee ever. The first second generation Blizzard employee.
First second generation Blizzard employee. So I'm second generation
Blizzard. I'm the first second generation Blizzard employee uh
that ever existed. >> Wow. I'm also >> Holy. It's
fat Steven Crowder.
What the I can't be the only one who sees this. Fat Steven Crowder
working at Blizzard in like 1995. Tell me you don't see that.
Tell me you don't see it. That's crazy.
What the You don't see that? That's crazy. The hell? >> I'm
the first second generation. >> Can you explain why Steven
Crowder is also Canadian? I believe he was born in >> and
Blizzard employee uh that ever existed at the company. I'm also
a second generation Blizzard employee. I was a second generation
Blizzard employee. I was the first the first second generation
Blizzard employee ever. I was the first second generation Blizzard
employee and I love that. I love that company. Working for Blizzard
sucked. And I work at Blizzard or I I worked at Blizzard. There
there's me eating a sandwich. Yeah, that was actually a Blizzard.
I think it was my first I think it was 2009. It was me picking
a safe. This me cracking a safe in um
at Blizzard. Your Blizzard stories are fake. Which Blizzard story
do you think is fake? Would you like to talk to me or my dad
that worked at Blizzard for 23 years that's currently in chat?
Which one do you want?
He doubled up. He doubled the up. Doubled down on Blizzard. Stop
saying my Blizzard stories are fake or I'm going to call my dad.
My dad's here right now. My dad doesn't like you. My dad could
totally beat up your dad if it's about working at Blizzard
anyway. Okay. Give me uh two seconds here. Okay. What's the What's
the next thing? The next thing is
this tweet. This tweet we saw come out. Okay. Everybody's eating
up Pirate Software's downfall. Okay. Pirate Software has lost
over 100,000 YouTube subscribers in two weeks. It came after
he was accused of misrepresenting the Stop Games campaign and
later criticized it himself. Wait, and later criticized it himself.
Criticized his previous takes or anyway, where's my where's my
social blade? There it is. There it is.
Yeah, it's been it's been rough this since January. Yeah, since
since the Blizzard stuff, sorry, since the Blizzard stuff, since
the World of Warcraft stuff, he's kind of been stagnant totally.
Losing subs, losing views,
just falling the off in a general sense, unfortunately. He had
this massive blow up start of 2024. Made his money was not long
for this world.
Still 33 million views. I think a lot of this is shorts still.
I think his shorts still clean up quite a bit. So, I don't know
how much money this these views are worth. Right now, let's see
the JTO YouTube. Oh, well, unfortunate for us. How are his streams
doing? Let's check it out. Sullyome. Sillyome. No,
Instead of not soite, let's go pirate software.
All right. Pirate software. Hello. Hello. Let's go past year.
Let's check it out. 365 days, please. Can we get the 365 view?
So, it's a clear downward trend.
>> But, I mean, it's not doing horribly. Still 5,000 6,000
live viewers and then what do we we need playboard to do? Let
me go to playboard. I'll find just give me a second under the
screen. So it's it's not I mean it's more than half the average
has come down I think. Right. So hold on. Can I move this window
back? Move the window like this into like the big part of his
his upswing here. Oh, I don't think the numbers aren't moving
up here. Damn it. 10,000 average viewers in the past 365 days
though. So 10,000 average past 365. It seems like around after
yeah after January he experiences a pretty large fall off like
a half cut down in viewers basically. Maybe even lower.
That's pretty rough.
Maybe those all went to YouTube though. Hold on. Hold on. We
could save it. We could save it. We go look up Pirate Software
on YouTube. We see
this many subs. Can you maybe not though?
>> Hold on. Turning my VPN back on so I can try to use
Playboard.
Okay. Can you not playboard?
>> I am doing a capture on another window.
>> Okay. Here we go. >> Pirate Software live. Let's
go to his live streams.
So, he is not averaging enough here to make up for the loss.
Averaging about he's getting about 600 700 views on over on YouTube
on his live streams. Even that's fallen off a decent amount over
the past couple days. So, he is not averaging enough here to
make up for the loss on Twitch. It's a pretty big loss on Twitch
since the January World of Warcraft stuff. 15,000 viewers. Now,
if we go back before this, maybe Only Fangs. Only Fangs might
have been buffing him a lot. No, he was 10,000 average. He was
he was cracked up to 10,000 average. He may have been a little
higher.
So, so yeah, he he had a major fall off after the after leaving
the um Only Fangs Guild, right? After the whole Wow drama, he
went really sparse on streams compared to usual,
which is weird cuz he streams lots.
I don't know why this seems sparse here. Let's go look at this.
He he did start streaming a little bit less, it looks like. Interesting.
Minus uh minus 150k subs in the past month. Yeah, that's true.
Let's check this out on on Twitch. See what he got for subs.
Lost.
>> Uh about 60,000 subs on Twitch. Lost, it looks like.
Yeah, about 60,000, maybe
>> Don't he stream 15 hours a day? He does stream quite
a while. Yeah, we had the social blade up here just a second
ago. Did I close it? I must have. Unfortunate. View stats.
Pirate
software. Oh no, I I spelled it wrong. Pirate software on view
stats. Let's see here. One year minus 380K subs on the year.
Minus 150k subs in the past 3 months on view stats. Eh, ouch.
Oof. Ouch. Ouch. Ow. Yeah, not good. Has he actually lost views?
Uh, it doesn't look like he's lost views particularly. Um, his
views are going down week by week. So, I guess yeah, you would
say he's losing views like he is week over week losing views
over the pre previous weeks. It looks like it's pretty rough
over the past year. It looks like again in January he was up
here. He was way up and then it was a big fall off. He kind of
was rising back up and then he oh, he started beating again.
Pirate is a multi-millionaire. What is losing Twitch viewers
matter that much? You think he's a multi-millionaire? I don't
know about that.
From what I remember, he's not been that big on Twitch for that
long. Like, I don't think he's been a multi-millionaire sized
streamer for that long.
Well, let me go back
go back more than a year. How long has he been a 10,000 viewer
streamer for?
like February 2024, he's like, okay, let's say 2024 is where
he breaks like about 5,000 average viewers, right? He's had a
YouTube channel since 2016. He was not big before this February
2024 mark. He wasn't big then. Hold on, let me pull up the Social
Blade again. Right. He just got big. Like just very, very, very
recently got big. Let me check this out. So, he only just recently
got big. It's like back here where he gains like a ton of subs
over on on YouTube. He is not that big before this. His views
are not big before this. They're like 30,000, right? He's had
>> what is this? Essentially a year and a half of being
a very big creator.
I don't know that he's a multi-millionaire based on that. Based
on he sends a lot of funding over that ferret rescue. He does
a lot of stuff, right? Yeah. Like he he he puts a lot of money
back into his businesses. He may not actually make he might not
be a multimillionaire. He might not be set for life. He has not
been a big creator for a long time.
>> The funny thing is, the funniest thing about all of
this is he didn't have to be the guy who went and challenged
other people on a bunch of their right. If he could just be humble
in moments where he was wrong, he didn't have to lose any of
this. Right?
>> You aren't looking at I'm looking at views. Hold on.
Hey, Reactable.
Do you think he was making a lot of money off of 300,000 views
in a month? September 2023? You think that was big a big month
for him? 300,000.
The month before August 2023, 30,000 views.
>> Do we think he was making a lot of money off of 30,000
views on YouTube?
>> Maybe 300,000 you could start getting into, oh, maybe
he's making a decent amount of money. But this is shorts, right?
This is shorts. when he actually starts getting like 200 million
views on
>> I'm the and you aren't looking at the right tools. Yes,
actually you are embarrassing yourself right now. Why Why would
we think that somebody who's getting view like the like Riyle
gets this many views on his right for my YouTube channel like
for for running like uh uh I said that wrong for running a channel
that primarily uses like VODs from my stream, right? That like
can't even be attached to me in any way. like can't even doesn't
even use my name on anything. Like the SEO is like kind of on
it.
>> Oh, no, no, no. I love the fact that Rialy's channel
exists, but you have to understand that that's like a massive
channel, right?
>> You're getting like 30,000 views.
>> I think Riyle probably gets more than 30,000 views a
month. Hold on.
Let me let me just check it for SocialBlade.
this in the past month. Oh, this is doing 200,000 views. >> So,
Riyle was kind of like Riyle for the past, you know, 6 months
or so is sort of mogging the out of Pirate Softwar's pre 2024
income and pre2024 views. So, I don't know how you think this
guy could be a multimillionaire from his YouTube channel. His
Twitch like pre2024 was not breaking 5,000 viewers and before
November 2023 is not even breaking um it's not even breaking
500. It's like 500 average viewers in November. Okay, he actually
before November. So, we go back to October. It's less than 500
average views. This guy objectively has not been a big creator
for more than a year and a half by like any possible measure.
You calling Ry a broki? No, I'm not calling Riyle a broki. I'm
saying Riyle Riyle literally just uses like uh like Riyle's like
giga from being able to actually market that channel in the way
that would be like good, right? If he but then if I I guess also
if I was tied to the channel, if I could, you know, if the channel
could be promoted correctly, then also at the same time,
uh I would probably have my own channel or something. But on
top of that, most of his views are shorts, which don't make Yeah,
this reactable guy is just kind of moronic. Like a complete nutter
[__] I don't understand what this guy's arguing that
there is a way that Pirate Software could have made as much in
2023. Like look, here's view stats, right? This is views all
time up until
what is it? October 2023, he had 2.7 million views on his channel
all time. It's sad. Anyway, so any suffice to say, Pirates offer
kind of getting put through the ringer. Hold on, let's look at
subs here. Give me subs.
So he was still growing growing hits a peak in right before the
WoW stuff. WoW stuff hits actually the WoW stuff didn't hit his
subbase that hard. It hit his viewership didn't hit his subbase
and then now the stop game stuff in his last couple dramas. O
kind of destroying him. Kind of just absolutely obliterating
him. Not great. Not good. Not fun. Okay.
From there,
do we want to check this video? No, I don't think so. I don't
think so. I think where we're going to go next is some of the
Discord crash outs. Give me a sec. Okay, I just had some thought
to go somewhere now. I lost it. Lost it. Lost it. You know what?
Actually,
I lied. I am going to check this video out because the crash
that we're going to look at is largely over the coding Jesus
stuff and the criticisms of his game's code. And so there's this
will be a quick refresher on the game code and stuff. We can
go through it. We can check it out. All right. I think so. The
Discord crashes will come, but this will be a quick refresher
for anybody who's unaware. Guys, we're going to also go over
to Kick Only. You're watching on Twitch, head over to kick, kick.com/jok.
Thank you very much for watching on Twitch. We're going to do
the rest of the stream on kick only. Okay, join us over there.
We're going to keep the party going. We'll probably go for a
couple more hours over on kick. Here we go. Here we go.
Multireaming with partner income. Back off. Okay, we pinned.
We pinned. All right. Ending the Twitch stream now. We'll see
you guys in just a second. Boop. What's up, guys? What's up?
I still can't believe people diluted themselves into thinking
wasn't hot out of spite. What? And will never understand this
joy. I don't know. Difficult for me to say, man. Difficult for
me to say from one picture, but you're uh you're a gooner, Hoszle.
You you probably know better than me. Hot Software is estimated
to have a net worth of around $2.79 million. This estimate is
based on their YouTube channels earnings, which include ad revenue
from videos and potential income from subscriptions. The channel's
over 2.57 million. So, here's the thing.
Most of that channel's video views are from shorts before they
had the upgrade in ad revenue.
So, any any tool that's not taking into account how much his
shorts are making is almost certainly going to be incorrect.
Right. In any case, I just wasn't sure about his uh his income
getting there overall
given his expenses. All right, >> Champions of Breakfast
and Heart were creating the Game Maker engine. Champions of Breakfast
is the game Jason claims has the unpiritable DRM. >> I
tried to find a way so that our game wouldn't get pirated because
it'd be easy to pirate it. This is your save file. First, start
the game up. It actually checks what achievements you have and
it unlocks powers based on your achievements. This is actually
the save file for the character. So, you can't pirate it because
you can never use the achievements. It made it unpiratable, which
is deeply hilarious. So, as you saw, essentially the DRM for
Champions of Breakfast is the Steam achievements acting as a
quasi save file. The Heartbound DRM is the following code snippet
that Jason has shown live on stream multiple times. Now, recently
a lot of people have been posting
Heartbound has always online DM. That is false. Heartbound does
not have always online DM. The DRM approach does not require
online connectivity to function. It'll work just fine with Steam
in offline mode. Jason has told the truth in regards to this
matter, so he doesn't deserve the online DRM hate he's getting
currently. Second, the Steam Achievements acting as a save file
is >> Wow, he was telling the truth in that >> Only
in Champions of Breakfast. Heartbound does not have any dependence
on Steve achievements. These are two completely separate DRM
solutions. Now let's start analyzing the Heartbound DRM code.
The important variable we need to pay attention to within the
code is on line three. The global.pirated game variable that
is set to one. Like the variable name suggests, this is what
dictates whether or not the game is considered pirated within
the game itself. A value of one implies the variable has a truthy
value. Normally for this type of thing, we use a boolean and
use true and false as the variable values directly, but we'll
leave that aside for now and touch on. Okay, I this it better
not just be all over over all of his um his using it as as bulls,
which is wrong under the games like uh sorry the engine and engine
language guides style or whatever. They explain why, but it's
like it's such a trivial it's so trivial to me. And again, in
the code review section, if we continue and move on to line five,
we can see the DRM process goes as follows. First, we check to
see if Steam is initialized. Once if it's confirmed to be true,
the game is considered legitimate. Hence, line seven. Then in
line 13, we check to see if the Steam client is actually a Steam
emulation or crack. The double equal sign means we're checking
to see if the value of this function is equal to the ASI string
IGG games. IGG games is an unsafe piracy group and they use their
name when they package their crack Steam games. Then we set the
game to pirated on line 14. If we confirm it's an I if it's oh
if it's a if it's from one of these explicit pirating groups,
boom, pirated
games copy of the game. Now we move on to line 16 where we check
to see if there's a bogus account ID. We also on line 19 check
to >> Yeah, but the bogus dude, what is what >> see
if we have a known Steam app ID that is commonly used in cracks
or playing pirated games or mods. If >> this is the worst
this is the worst >> one of these checks end up being true,
we also set the pirated game variable to true. Now, in order
for us to break this DRM, the first two problems we have to deal
with is the function call of Steam initialized and the Steam
DM that would be included with the actual game. Steam DRM is
Steam's own add-on DRM. It is completely separate from the Heartbound
DRM we're discussing. Due to legal reasons, I'm not going to
directly show what programs to use or how to bypass Steam Functions
and Steam DRM, but I'll explain a bit about the process and how
secure using Steam Functions as a form of DRM is. First, let's
talk about the Steam DM. The Steam DM has been well understood
by cracking groups for a very long time. It's so well understood
and commonly cracked, there are multiple tool sets built for
it and guides to the point even non-technical users can use them
to crack and distribute their own Steam games. This is called
Home Rifts, and this is one of the reasons there's so many Steam
games that have day one cracks floating around. Next, we have
the Steam functions that we saw in the Heartbound DRM code that
we need to >> That all makes sense. >> The Champions
of Breakfast DRM for this issue. Let's talk about Steam. >> [__]
this guy's just teaching me, so I have a hard time throwing almost
any >> Emulators, these are programs that mimic some legitimate
Steam client functions and fake some of the other functionality
you expect in the legitimate Steam client. There are numerous
Steam client emulators and I'm not going to touch any of these
emulators, but take my word for it that they could easily get
through the Steam DRM and the initialized function check and
they can also so this would just be basically I'm guessing how
would you communicate through this? You'd almost certainly use
like a a port or something to communicate between these two applications,
right? Like they'd open up some port and then you would just
have essentially the API calls going through that port that you'd
right? Like the Steam client would be on some port. it would
get calls from like a video game. They'd be checking in on that
port and yeah, it would be I think it would be pretty simple.
>> So mimic the Steam Achievement API, meaning not only
can the Steam DRB be bypassed by using these emulators, but they
would also allow you to crack and play Champions of Breakfast,
plus you'd basically have a save game editor along with the two.
While we're on the topic of Champions of Breakfast, I was curious
how long it took for the game with the unpiritable DRM to be
cracked after it was released. And this is what I found. 1 day
and 17 hours after the game was released on Steam, there was
already a home floating around. if you don't consider home rips
to be valid. I also checked to see if any known wear seam groups
had a crack for the game. The seam group simplex has also had
a crack for the game floating around for years at this point.
So that unpartable DRM has been soundly defeated multiple times
just after launch. Now with those problems addressed, let's return
to the heartbound DRM code and examine the last problem we need
to figure out how to break. Namely, the IGG games check and the
various ID checks setting the pirated game variable to true.
In order to break this, we'll need to do some reverse engineering.
To make this reverse engineering and cracking process smoother
to explain, I've copied over the snippet of code into a tiny
C++ program. The DRM I have in it is in the left pane between
lines 13 to 51. Now, you might notice I have a couple functions
here between lines 15 to 33. Those are just placeholders. Due
to legal reasons, I'm not including the real Steam SDK or functions
in my tiny program or including it within the actual reverse
engineering process. Since I already explained how they can be
defeated, it's not important to include them in the program.
Back to our code. You can see the rest of the DRM matches up
basically one to one with the DRM snippet we have from Heartbound.
Last line. >> Why? What is the point of this? I maybe I'm
I understand what's going on here. So, I don't know what the
point of this >> I run the DRM check here on line 108 just
after the program starts. The rest of my program code doesn't
matter too much. I'm basically just using the Windows native
wind32 API to create a simple window that will have a red background
if the game is pirated. And if it's a legitimate copy, the background
will be green. Also, just like the Heartbound DRM code, we start
the program assuming to be in a pirated state. Now, I compiled
the little app we have and we have an exe we can run. Let's pretend
we don't have the actual source code and just have the .exe.
So, how do we modify the .exe and beat the DRM? In order to modify
the CXE, >> you change the output of the function. >> We'll
need to use what is known as a dissembler plus a debugger. I'll
be using Ali debug, which is a very old and outdated x86 debugger.
If someone was doing actual reverse engineering these days, the
tools they would look for and use would probably be something
like a pro or gedra, a reverse engineering tool built by the
NSA and freely available on GitHub to download and use. Anyways,
let's open up. >> This is a technical video. Did a lot
a lot of streamers watch this too. A lot of streamers like put
this video up and and watch the whole thing. This is a very technical
video. I'm very confident this guy will have like good critiques.
By the way, >> debug and attach a little DRM test application
and see what we get. So, here in the main window, we have something
that is called assembly. This is normally the lowest low-level
programming language used and is very tidily corresponds to machine
code. And these are the instructions your computer or phone CPU
is actually executing when you're using a program. The other
window panes don't matter at all for our purposes. So, we can
>> wait. How do you Well, I I guess he's not going to explain
any of this any of this assembly. These are registers. These
are on your CPU. Um, you basically move things uh from memory
into a register so that it can be read and used in some program,
right?
You handle that with uh with them. Next, I'm going to run this
program as just smoke test to make sure everything is working
as we expect it to. Namely, we see the red background and the
pirate game detect the stuff we expect from our DM. I don't need
the live attached process info, so close the app and return to
the view we had originally when we opened the exe. Now, remember
earlier how I mentioned IG. So, basically what this is saying
is
um it's using the it's it's running the program and it's just
showing you the assembly that's spit out. This is like a Yeah,
this is disassembly. This is um
>> I guess it's kind of like decompiling, right? This would
not be equivalent to decompiling games. was an ASKI string. Well,
that's what we're going to search for. Since the string isn't
offiscated and will be in plain text, we can easily search for
it and hunt it down. All right, I see two IG game strings in
our search. Let's just go and open the first one and see what
code is there. The first function looks similar to our stub function
in our C++ code. The second IG game strings is just a bit beneath.
So, let's look at that. Now, we see something interesting. Notably,
the dword pointer and the line ending with zero. If we look just
a few more lines below, we see more dword pointer lines. Except
these ones end with one. I hope everyone is catching on and you've
realized these are >> uh dword pointer. This is a pointer
that takes two words. So it's probably what like an 8 bit pointer
then bit 8 bit >> the lines of our original C++ >> I
think a word a word length should be four bits right >> plus
source code setting the pirate game variable. Now since we already
know this is the dear function what happens if we change the
values in those lines below to zero. >> Oh I'm so wrong.
Oh god.
Oh god. I'm so I'm so out of date with everything. I I took my
assembly course like a decade ago. Okay, I took my assembly course
a decade ago. I don't remember any of this garbage.
God, I'm like all that changed. Running a little application
again.
>> Wait. Oh, I'm so I'm so dumb. I'm so dumb. It's like
actually inexplicable
>> and we've successfully cracked the DM since now the
pirated game variable. >> This is nothing to do with leak
code problems. I could do that stuff far more easily. This is
more This is like lower every point in our program code will
always report. I'm going to stop trying to pretend I I know what
this is doing. I've written like some somewhat complex I I wrote
a operating system. I wrote it like a bare metal operating system
with a Zod. >> Now, I'm sure many of you watching have
questions and concerns. Stuff like what if pirate never shared
the DRM code. You wouldn't be able to do this so easily and quickly
or maybe something like your app was made in C++, Heartbound
is made in Game Maker, so the output files and structure would
be different. First, >> I think you would basically Okay,
let me guess because he's going to explain what happens when
the DRM gets triggered and how it changes. You go with the um
you go with the line that would do that to some window. You work
backwards from that and then you can figure out what has what
conditional has triggered that actual thing to happen. Let's
pretend we didn't know what the DM code looked like and we're
doing a real blind reverse engineering attempt at cracking the
DM. Let's go through the scenario. Let's assume we already have
the original game files. Now we open the game and let's say we're
using one of those Steam client emulators I mentioned from earlier
in the video. Let's say we're playing through >> Oh, you
could
was it Steam name you're looking for? You would have probably
just some idea of how they check for DRM >> through hardbound
and trying to find information to use. >> So you'd use
you could hook onto the emulator.
Well, we're in luck since Heartbound has a piracy message. if
you somehow manage to pull this exact scenario I'm describing.
Here's a screenshot from a user that owns a legitimate copy of
the game and they managed to trigger this pirate message on their
Steam Deck. Meaning two things. One, the DM is so bad it has
false positive activations which I find funny. And two, we have
our unique identifile mostly unobuscated ask string to search
for in our debugger. The part >> Yeah, exactly. Well, it
wouldn't even have to be you could look for almost anything that
was popular. >> Message string is unique enough that we
can use it to hunt down the DM code within the debugger. The
reason being in order for the message to appear it has to either
be checking the pirated game variable or is close to the DRM
check function cuz otherwise it wouldn't be able to be triggered.
In either case, we have enough info from this alone to hunt down
the DM and break. It would be there on the the stack. In any
case, >> even we didn't have the original DRM code snippet
for reference. Now, let's talk about the C++ versus Gamemaker
issue. Game Maker is a game. Oh, can I could I explain this?
Because because you'd have to be going through the DRM functionality.
you would expect like okay when the DRM message pops up that's
going to be oh I'm not I can't even explain this stuff if you've
never taken these courses never mind >> I was gonna explain
explain like stack frames and stuff but basically when you call
something like you're in the middle of calling drm function and
it's like you tell the computer like hold on wait hold pretend
that I pretend that I'm taking a pause here hold on to that call
exactly where I was now you've called the function I'm going
to go somewhere else right you can step backwards through that
and step back through the stack frames you can step you have
like a stack pack of function calls. You can step backwards through
that to see where this is actually. >> It has its own process
packing up a game built together and will include much more files
than just a single .exe. You might think this would make the
cracking process more difficult, but the exact opposite is actually
true. The reason is game maker builds are something that is well
understood and there are lots of decompilation tools. You might
remember me using the term compilation earlier in the video.
So, let me explain these two terms a bit more clearly. Now, when
you have, for example, our C++ source code and you're trying
to turn it into an executable the computer can run, this is called
compilation. the process of turning code into instructions the
computer can actually understand and can execute. Decompilation
is the pro. Do you like functional programming? Lisp, Haskell,
Mr. Jtock. Um, I've done some functional programming stuff. Nothing
really crazy.
I've never done Lisp. I did Haskell. I actually brought up learn
you a Haskell cuz the coding Jesus guy who reviewed this video
when we first or reviewed the code, the first guy we watched
review the code, um, that guy was talking about how he had a
whole bunch of books and I'm like books are garbage. Programming
books suck. Except learn you a hasll for great good. Okay, learn
you a hasll for great good. That's a fantastic book.
Love that book. Okay, that's an awesome book. Process in reverse.
You have some kind of application and you're trying to convert
it back into what the original source code looked like. Meaning
you can use a demp tool on the Game Maker build and get back
gamemaker language code that it looks somewhat close to the original
source code. Which also >> nice. If it can be de decompiled
really easily, then you can do a full code review. you have an
easier time hunting down the darham code since it's easier to
reason about in a game maker language than it is in raw assembly.
So the C++ reverse engineering example I demonstrated is actually
harder and more worst case scenario relatively speaking to trying
and figure out the crack. Now to the last question everyone might
have. What if that pirated game variable didn't exist and you
couldn't change the value to zero? Well, nothing changes even
if that was the case. There are are there are other good programming
books but there I think the other ones I've looked at are
yeah so low-level books would be good because that stuff basically
doesn't change but I would say highle language books not usually
that good and which is what this guy was referencing um there
are some fairly good books that exist out there um
I've never read this book though I've never had this book even
recommended to me could be interesting
could be interesting I'm thinking of Um, oh, there's like a there's
an algorithms book that has some name. It's known by like the
anagram of the not an anagram. It's known as a like amalgamation
of the letters at the start of the author's last name. CLR. Is
it like CLR? Algorithms. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This this book is
like pretty well known as like a theory book. Introduction to
algorithms.
Lizersonen Revest and Stein. Yeah. This one is uh you take an
algorithms class, they'll they'll do this. Oh, that piece of
Yeah, a lot of people would have learned from that book. A lot
of people would have liked that class. Yeah. Why? Well, the DM
is so stupidly simple and there isn't any application security
measures to prevent reverse engineering or tampering with it.
We could have just ripped out the entire DM function and left
it empty. We could have found the places the DM checks were called
and removed them instead. Regardless of what we chose, there's
at least a few dozen working options to pick from. And all this
also applies to the actual Heartbound game, not just to the tiny
C++ program I wrote. To be thorough, I'll also cover some application
security metrics that could be added and some TRM measures, but
I'll keep it light and just at a high level overview since diving
into those is way too out of scope for this video. First of all,
let's go back to our C++ source code. Something we could add
to prevent all debug from opening up our exe would be to add
the native wind32 function is debugger present. Yes, that one
line would help stop some of the simplest debuggers from opening
the exe. Next, we could also add something called string opiscation,
meaning we don't need Okay, I actually don't Is he going to He
does code reviews, right? I'm I'm sorry.
As cool as this is, I just can't imagine most people care. That's
like incredibly
the pirate message and easy to search for format. By obuscating
and having a special function to decode the real strings, we
could have prevented the search string stuff we did in the cracking
process. Another simple thing we could do is what's called a
check sum. Basically, we can have our own application look at
part of itself and generate a special result from that. So, in
the case if someone tried to crack the application by removing
the DRM, the application portion being checked would be different.
meaning the checks I'm generating now would be different from
what's expected and as a result would fail. These are fairly
common additional layers of defense for programs to help prevent
tampering the distributed program by end users. All right, with
all that I think we can start wrapping up the CRM analysis and
yes, there's a million more things that could have been done
and yes, there's a ton more application. I'm sure dude this guy
is not a good programmer. Okay, I >> security measures
that could be added. There's entire standard bodies around it.
I just barely scratched the surface. Also, I'm not a hacker.
Do you want KCIP? Hold on. I don't do this type of work professionally
and I don't mess around with this stuff in my free time either.
I'm a complete novice when it comes to this area. But for context,
if I didn't stop this video every few seconds to explain what
was going on, the first attempt I took at a crack in the DM in
total uninterrupted would have been 37 seconds altogether. Now,
let's return to Jason and see a tweet plus a short where he mentions
his assembly and reverse engineering experience. I'm a hacker.
I've been a hacker for 20 years. Part of my job throughout that
was working in the games industry. I was one of the guys sitting
there pulling down every bot that worked for every MMO that we
worked on, everything at Blizzard. grabbed every single one of
those, pulled it out into assembly, grabbed the code K from it,
removed the polymorphic. This section is pretty long. I don't
know what any of that means. And I feel like basically by putting
such DRM into his game, it's very unlikely,
right? It's very unlikely that if he says all of those things,
it's like he knows those words, he knows somebody smart would
say those words, but he doesn't know what those mean either,
right? Or else probably he would have done any of the things
this guy suggested for like hiding his uh hiding his Oh, wait.
This YouTube Twitch game bro says he's been a hacker for 20 years
and did Andy cheat stuff at Blizzard said he pulled it out into
assembly, grabbed the code cave, and removed the polymorphic.
What the is this guy talking about? Oh, look, it's a response.
In this case, code cave was the term we used to describe where
cheating tools were injected uh tools injected themselves into
the client for their hook. This is generally done in an area
of nonv volatile memory, meaning it won't get overwritten. Stable
area of injection equals code cave. Okay, sure.
At times we would see hooks like this change per run with bogus
push pop commands that did nothing overall. This is in assembly.
Uh this feature is called polymorphism or can be described as
polymorphic code, meaning it changes the structure without changing
the function. They do this
this they do this to make automatic detection more difficult
as the signature will not be the same.
>> So it's basically saying they add some they add something
in that makes it um they add an abstraction in that lets it inject
through multiple places so it doesn't have one repeated hook
in making it more easy. They just check that memory address and
you're long. So, we'll save breaking down the code cave and polymorphic
code comments and nonsense and his comments to VX underground
for maybe a part three video related to his hacking claims. The
only part from here we need to care about for now is Jason has
confirmed to have done reverse engineering and gone through and
read assembly similar to what we did earlier. That was another
reason I chose to use C++ and all debug since those would have
been the language and tool he would have been using during his
time period at Blizzard or earlier since those were some common
choices back then. Now, while in part well I leaned towards distrust
but it gave him the benefit of doubt on a few of his hacking
points. I think it's clear to see Jason doesn't seem to know
a whole lot on how to create a secure application or how to set
up a real custom DRM solution. And while this entire video I've
been referring to all this as DRM, it really doesn't deserve
to be called as such. I can fairly confidently say Jason barely
has any application hacking knowledge that you would expect someone
to have with his supposed history and experience. So the fact
he doesn't even seem to understand any of these concepts or problems
makes me fairly confident saying his reverse engineering and
assembly claims are mostly madeup stories or complete and outright
lies. Let's leave the DRM stuff behind us now and move towards
the code. >> That's what I said. >> Before I start
doing the reviews, >> this smart guy just agreed with me.
I love to see it. Although his name is Slop News Network, so
that's awesome that Slop News Network. Okay, this is like the
new This is the new code path. Okay, this is the learn new uh
this is the new learn to code. Okay, actually guys, make slop
YouTube videos.
Coders, coding's done. Slop YouTube videos. AI could never AI
could never make slop YouTube videos.
Okay, it could never compete. Bang, bang, boom. >> Let
me give some additional context. If you watch part one, you wouldn't
know. >> I love you, J. I'm a VOD watcher. Oh, thank you,
Caleb. I appreciate it. >> Jason supposedly started doing
dev stuff in 2002. Meaning at this point in 2025, he has 23 years
of experience programming. When he started working on his first
game, Champions of Breakfast, he had somewhere around 13 years
of experience. So, when he started seriously working on Heartbound,
he should have been very familiar with Game Maker and the Game
Maker language. Also, he's the owner of the game studio and the
only person who's ever touched the code on the Heartbound game.
So, I don't want to hear any nonsense like his code's bad on
purpose for job security or someone else wrote the garbage code
and he inherited and has to maintain it. Lastly, all the code
we're going to look at is modern and should still be in the game
based on what I could find from his live streams. So, this is
a reflection of his current abilities. I'll be saving all my
comments related to Jason's coding abilities for after I finish
all the code reviews. Also, let me break down my criteria and
rules I set for myself so everyone understands why I chose these
code snippets and how I'll be offering advice and comments on
them. First off, the code snippet had to be something I had confirmed
to be shown on Jason's streams. I had a ton of people sending
me code snippets in text over the last few days. So, while it
might be Jason's code, if I couldn't confirm it, I decided to
skip it for the sake of fairness. So, every code snippet we'll
review today is something I can personally verify has been shown
on one of his streams and is legitimate heartbound code. Second
off, the code needs to be a reoccurring problem or have significant
impact on a large part of the code base. So, I won't be reviewing
some Okay, I do want to see what he says about the magic numbers.
I actually do. I hope this guy doesn't think the magic numbers
are a big issue. Maybe you could argue the color ones could be.
Anyway, I'll just give me two seconds. I need two seconds to
get more water. I didn't drink anything before stream, so I just
my voice was I've just been slurping down water the whole time.
Script some small unimportant object like some random pre-object
that has an attached script. This I think is kind of pointless
to review. So, I skipped those kind of super lowhanging fruits.
Thirdly, unless I absolutely have to, I won't drastically change
the code. I'll offer solutions and improvement paths that can
be taken to make the current code reach some junior level baseline
of quality. Also, I'll limit my advice to things that are possible
in the Game Maker language and engine. So, design patterns and
practices that are possible in other engines or languages, but
not easily doable or possible in GameMaker, I'll be skipping.
Fourth, I largely won't be talking about performance. We're just
trying to get the code to something readable that a real development
team could realistically understand and work on. Having performance
discussion and talking about entirely different data structures
and game design patterns is too far removed from the topics of
this video. Plus, the Heartbound game is extremely simple, so
additional improvements here won't truly matter. Fifth, if I
basically covered all the issues another code snippet would have,
I won't cover the other similar snippets. Basically, there are
like a 100 files with the exact same problems and issues. So,
if I address the issues other code snippets would have during
the other snippet reviews, I'll skip over anything too similar
so this video isn't stupidly long and repetitive. Yes, there's
that many problems with the codebase. I felt I needed to add
these rules and criteria. With all that out of the way, let's
start with some actual code reviews. We'll bring back the DM
snippet and we'll open up a few other snippets as well. If you
remember at the start of the video, I talked about truthy and
falsy values on the pirated game >> Booleans. We're going
to go through the booleans. We're going to go through the booleans.
And I brought up the term boo. >> Dude, I'm going to I
By the way, this guy this guy clearly knows what he's talking
about. I'm going to maintain the same position on those magic
numbers. I'm going to maintain the exact same position and I
don't care. I understand. Listen, I know really good devs who
disagree with me. I know really good devs who agree with me when
I've had this exact argument a hundred times working an actual
job. I'm not gonna I'm not gonna back down just because this
guy says it. Okay. >> Booleans are basic data type in nearly
all he's going to have to justify you true and false directly
when you're checking to see if a variable is well true or false.
So if we look at these code snippets, we can see Jason is using
zero or one in numerous places instead of using the appropriate
data types and values. This is a sign of a more amateur programmer.
I just wanted to clear this up now so we won't have to repeat
this in every single code snippet we look at. Now, let's drill
down into a specific code snippet. We'll start with the one from
the bottom left. All right, so the very first line, we already
have a lot of issues here. So, Jason is accessing a storyline
flag in a single dimensional global array using a raw index number
of 367. Both of those things are terrible, but let me explain
what an array is first. Arrays are a basic data structure that
stores a collection of elements. Let's go through a >> It's
a big It's a big list of boxes. It's a list of boxes. It's a
list. >> Quick examples. Imagine you have a row of boxes
and inside each box you had >> What is he going to Oh,
what did we say? I I think I said if I just had an enume that
explained what each of these things was in that array. That's
like the minimum I would need to be okay with this. You could
use a dictionary, but to be honest,
an array with um an enum is basically like a dictionary to me.
It's not quite the same. Obviously, you don't have dictionary
functions in the same way, but it's it's fine. Use a strruct.
Uh I don't think using a strct here would make sense. Why doesn't
it make sense? He's like he was uh he was doing like multivariable
or so he he had like he's storing states and it's like multi-
multi-sized states and the states it's like like he's using like
an unsigned integer to correspond to states hashmap is fine.
Yes, which is what I just said. What is what is an array? Okay,
it's fine. If you just have keys that are a part of an EU number
to access a number inside a specific box, you would use what's
called an index value. In Game Maker, array indexes start at
zero. Another nice thing with arrays, there are lots of functions
built into your program language, making it much nicer to work
with. Arrays are a basic program concept and near universal in
all languages. Now, let's deal with the index number 367. This
is what we call a magic number. Mag Oh, wait. I gave him for
this magic number, too. Hold on. I I said this had to change.
This is a magic number. When he's accessing this array without
an an enumerated value, when he's accessing it without like a
basically what would be a variable, a named variable, basically
what this should be is global storyline array and like outside
winter scene inanimus or something would be like the the variable
that would correspond to the number 367.
That's what you would use in this case. That's what I wanted.
But I made that recommendation. If this is his only magic number
critique here, then we're good. We're golden. Magic numbers in
programming are when you use a number directly to check or think
you said I don't care. I don't care about the 01 boolean thing.
I literally I literally don't give a about it. Um there there's
only like forward reaching consequences for that. I just don't
think it really matters that much in GameMaker language. It seems
like the booleans the booleans aren't implemented correctly,
right? It's whatever. It doesn't matter to me. Other people will
say it's like a big deal. It's like yeah, you should probably
follow the guide. They're like, "Oh, we might implement booleans
in the future. So, use this boolean wrapper because then all
of your comparisons will still work and they'll all be able to
use the boolean wrapper and maybe you'll be able to fix stuff
easier in the future. Okay, I don't care. Back to something.
And there's no way for someone reading it to have any idea what
it could possibly mean or refer to without someone else explaining
the intent or finding a different file that might hold the context
needed. Jason uses magic numbers across all his files and codebase.
So, for us to get context on this, let's pull up another code
snippet that has the story line array comments and logic. Okay,
there's another huge issue with this code snippet. Okay, there's
probably a way to try to store these states that make
but uh that's fine.
H I'm trying to think. You could use like an individual N.
Yeah, maybe maybe the argument should be that the you're storing
like a 012 or some number here, right? You probably for these
should be actually storing individual enumes for each of them
to say what they are. but >> something I'll refer to as
code change blast radius. To better understand what blast radius
is, let's imagine we're looking at lines with indexes of 207
and 208, dealing with something called middle story line flags.
Let's say one day we want to add another story line flag or event
for the section called middle. We have two options here. Option
one, we go to the end of this array and add in a completely unrelated
area of the array, another middle event. So this array has something
like 560 indexes, meaning if we added a new one at the end, our
middle event flags would be indexes 207, 208, and >> this
is why I use the >> 561. This is absolutely terrible since
logic and events that should be together are at completely random
spots inside the array. This causes a whole host of issues. The
code becomes difficult to reason about. The magic numbers become
even more challenging to maintain and use. It's so obtuse that
the odds of maintaining and using this code decreases the more
this array is expanded on. So what's option two? Well, it would
be
>> nicer if it was at line 209. So, it's logically grouped
together. But in order to do that, we need to bump all the under
indexes by one. So, the old 209 would be 210. Old 210 would be
211, etc. Unfortunately, this is what we call a nightmare code
change or refactor scenario. Since if we wanted to do that, we
would have to go now if you I will say, okay,
>> this can be done. This can be done, bro. I There's a
way to do this, right? There's a way to do this. If you man oh
if you didn't suck at said you could do this really well easily
right I think but it's just better to avoid this problem go by
hand and update every single index after 209 within this file
then we have a near 100% code change blast radius since if we
change those indexes every other file using those story line
flags is going to need to update their index number by one if
they're at the 209th index or greater essentially the structure
this is the issue is there's no variable that you attach across
files you're using the same thing here, right? You're saying
I need to use a key to identify which scene I'm trying to access,
but that key is not actually named in any way. It's just like
a sequential, it's like you have a a list of file folders in
a drawer. And if you wanted to actually organize that drawer
correctly, you have to insert a new file folder. But there's
no way to do that here because actually when somebody says they
want a file folder, they don't say, "I want the file folder for
this information." They say, "I want file folder 214." It's like
well actually file folders 210 to 220 are all about you know
our a logging of techone right and it's like oh I want to add
a new thing for a logging techone well actually when I want the
the file on techone you know te's dad being that's 210 or 220
215 let's say right I just ask for 215 I don't ask for the file
in that some I should have some way of saying hey brother man
get me the file and techone's dad being but instead I'm saying
get me file 215 and now when somebody wants to add a new Teetone
ALOG file. That might change 215 to 216. It's going to change
the ordering. So I now I'm now I'm right. I'll say 215. I'll
get a folder of Teone, you know, talking about sucking on some
8-year-old's feet. It's crazy. What are we doing here, guys?
This is amateur hour. So that's the issue that we have going
on. >> So bad and unwieldy, it's basically impossible to
maintain or extend in a good way as it is. Let's deal with the
magic number. If you understood what I was saying, that was such
a fantastic analogy that was just off the top of my head that
perfectly reiterated what this guy was saying for anybody who
didn't understand. My god, I'm so good at this. First, then we'll
discuss a better way to do the story flags. We have two options
when it comes to the magic index numbers. We can use const values
or enums. Const values are just a named variable with a value
that will never change. Enums are a data type that contains its
own list of named constants. Enums are a much nicer choice to
work with, so we'll go with them. With this enum defined, we
can update the global storyline array where index 207 and 208
are with the enum values. Now, isn't this better? Now, we have
some context for what the storyline array indexes for. Plus,
if we return to our previous code snippet, we could change all
these magic numbers into Hey, he said he'd wait until that 8-year-old
was 18 after he said it the first time. Yes, he did. Wait, hold
on. He said he said that before and then he talked about how
her feet would taste
first into analogies was a tectone analogy even more depraved.
A techone analogy where I talked about his father and his weird
thoughts around kids into enum values. So 367 could be an enum
force value. 333 could be an enum value for a town and the one
and two that is fern and road could also use a character enum.
Now we have our first code. Yeah. So if you're doing a switch,
I said this I I said I've had llinters. I'm almost positive I've
had llinters that if you do a switch statement without an enum
present that you actually like um you actually get
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. >> Oh, he's doing enims
of enims. Okay, okay, I got you. I got you. Characters up for
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, that makes sense. >> Improvement.
The storyline flag structure still isn't good, but we've reduced
the blast rate. I think I said this. I think I said, "Oh, the
characters need to also be an enim of changes from the entire
codebase to basically just one file." Since we have a nice abstraction
away from the raw index number, we just need to update the enum
and the storyline array to have new flag options without having
to update the rest of the codebase. This also helps with something
called developer experience, DX for short. Game Maker includes
what we call an IDE or integrated development.
So what's going to happen is in game maker if I if I access this
global storyline array sorry if I if I look at this enume and
other things reference this data type and I actually add something
new to this data type or I change the name of this data type
let's say town was actually Chinatown and now I'm adding like
I'm adding Chinatown in some other things Korea town or something
right I need to actually change this to Chinatown now I can just
go over to this type I can change it to Chinatown and all of
the places where I use town do something we'll change to Chinatown
something environment. Basically, an IDE helps you to code and
easily refer to code and values across your codebase. So, if
we use let's say the enum example and we start typing in middle
and then dot, the IDE would show us the values under the middle
enum. Meaning, we don't have to search for the file with the
enum to see what values we can use under that specific enum.
We also don't get a bunch of random type suggestions that don't
apply to the situation. Having good DX is important when working
in a team and argue critical if you're trying to build and program
something solo in a reasonable amount of time. So, we'll stop
worrying about the snippets since
>> Is it critical? I think I think it's critical to do
this in cases where it like is super easy like this should have
just been done because it makes everything better with like literally
no downside. Those situations you can Okay, I want to add an
abstraction. This abstraction. So when you want to add an abstraction
which is a way of uh not using you know layer one layer one thinking
you're you're like using something um that becomes repeatable
or reusable or makes things better. It's like adding complexity
to get something out of it. If you're not going to get something
out of the abstraction I don't like adding it. That's why I don't
care about the magic numbers in the particle situation because
I think you get nothing out of adding the abstraction of introducing
a constant instead of using the magic number. Right? In this
case you do get something. You get clarity. You get refactorability.
You get the developer experience stuff, right? You get lots of
things out of this. People who want to add abstractions in places
where they get nothing out of them me off. Okay. They me off
like that the coding Jesus guy that me off when he's like, "Oh,
you should actually start, you know, making const all these particle
numbers." Yeah, shut the up. So, use it in one place. No, shut
up. Get out of here. But this stuff, this >> half decent
code quality now and workable. Now, let's return to the global
storyline array. While our edum change is a huge improvement
over the original state of this file, this still isn't exactly
good. Now, before I offer a solution, let's see why Jason used
the flat single dimensional array in the first place. He's probably
going to say like a nested either a nested um nested array, nested
dictionary, whatever the right. So, you do all the closet things
together, all the middle things together, all the because breaking
that up probably makes it um again more readable instead of having
this all mashed into the same array. place. Yeah. So, according
to Jason, he has a flat array cuz he wants all the values to
be saved exactly the same way in the game save file so players
can modify it. Well, his reasoning is kind of dumb. What kind
of code structure you have and the save file format you want
do not impact.
That is literally good practice though. It can be good practice
and something I don't care about at the same time. Dolce bellum
inexpertise. I just love writing macros. Don't care if I could
do it in a function.
Okay, each other. Every single game that has a save file has
something called serialization, which is the process of taking
your game structure and data and converting into a format your
game will know how to read and reassign the values into the correct
places. This is serialization and deserialization, respectively,
and it's a basic concept when making a save file. This is literally
a basic thing nearly every single game has. So yes, it's perfectly
safe to not use the one-dimensional array here. Next, let's look
at a save file. So every line has a random number value that's
supposed to correspond to one of his array indexes. Since we
know what the problem is and what we need to achieve. Now, let's
actually code up a better solution. Let's start by >> God,
what are you going to use here?
Um, what is this? I I'm trying to think of >> change the
story line array into a strct. A strruct is a composite data
type. Basically, it's just a variable that can hold other variables
inside itself. Since we already know hardbound has five chapters,
I'll further split up the strrus for the five chapters to have
some separation of concerns. Here, we can see what the strrus
look like. We have at the top level our chapter. Then, we have
our area of that chapter. And finally within the third level,
we have our story line event. What's so nice with this approach
is we can now dish the enums entirely. We can access the story
line flags like this. For example, chapter one. This is probably
good. Uh
>> Caleb, thank you very much for the gifted sub to not
yab Bob. Thank you very much. I'm trying to think of like why
I wouldn't want to do it this way if I might not want to do it
this way. Yeah, there's something about the array. He wanted
it to be like like attached in memory, right? I guess actually
now that I think about it, that is the same with a strct. Oh,
I got goofed. God damn it. A strruct would be defined contiguously
in memory as well. I'm sure there's a way you could make it so
it would be the same, but dot middle dot Joe sunglasses. Not
only is this incredibly clear on what value we're trying to access,
but now we also have nearly no code change blast radius if we
want to modify a flag or add a new one. The setup also makes
it safer if we're working in a team since now if any changes
are made to any of these strcts. You wouldn't cause cascading
issues to the rest of the flags as was the case with the raw
index usage. While this is nicer to use, this isn't the only
benefit. In Game Maker, it's incredibly easy to iterate through
a strct. So, what we can do for the save game logic is the following.
We can take our strct, go through the key value pair, and since
we know the depth level, we can nicely format the save file to
include the chapter, the section, and the story flags. For example,
here we can clearly see which flag is for Joe's sunglasses.
Oh, wait. Is that what he said? Is that what he he was like,
"Oh, I want the save file to be formatted a certain way."
>> Oh, another huge benefit using these key values directly
from the strct is we added some freedom to make refactors and
code chases as possible since we have the struct chat per key
inside the safe. >> Ah, critical mistype.
Critical mistype chat per one, bro.
Dude, this guy's an idiot. Pirate software owns this guy. Okay.
Chat per >> file for the flag. In the future, if we wanted
to change our code order of flags, the struct of the save file
wouldn't matter. We'd still be able to easily read in the right
values. I think this is an important thing to care about. Since
the game hardbound is still in early access, the odds of changes
occurring to the various parts of the game are high. And with
this save file approach, we're basically in the clear to be as
wild with our code changes as we want and still ensure every
player that is keeping up with the game updates is never negatively
impacted by them. Also, one other minor thing, I threw in the
save file or version number at the top of our example. This helps
ensure if we're making drastic changes between game versions,
you can easily check what version of the save file you have and
internally how to update it. Basically, it's just a good practice
to ensure players aren't impacted by the behind-the-scenes work
in progress on the game. With this solution done, let's now look
at the code comments from the original snippet. With our structure
and clarity, we can start cutting out large portions of these
comments. We could keep the value conditions since that seems
fine. While on the topic of comments, let's pull up some of the
Hold on, hold on, hold on. >> Let's now look at the code
comments from the original snippet. With our structure and clarity,
we can start cutting out large portions of these comments. We
could keep the value conditions. Is that >> so the the
strruct man?
Can I get a one in the chat if you're just like, oh, all I'm
thinking about is like a fine. >> While on the topic of
comments, let's pull up some of the other snippets. Again, the
comment frequency is way too high in Jason's code. Code should
be self-documenting. Comments are perfectly fine to add if there's
some special condition or some other oddity surrounding the code
usage. But some of these code comments are just worthless. For
example, here he comments with this. I feel like I'm almost positive
he tried to talk through this with himself. Like he was literally
telling himself what this should be, what should be going on
here. The function call is going to do. There's no surrounding
code inside the brackets to affect the function and there's no
parameters. If this needs a comp to understand what it's going
to do, that means you should be renaming your function, not adding
a comment. Also, redundancy like question asked equals 1 and
set stuff is just wasting screen space. Maybe Jason was adding
this for his live viewers so they would have a reference what
he was coding, but leaving this in afterwards I find questionable.
Moving on to the next snippet, we have another array to look
at where Jason is manly setting each array element to mostly
the same value. First of all, manually setting every single array
index for hundreds of arrays. Okay, so there was a thing with
the alarms yesterday or whenever we covered this, I was like,
"Oh, you don't have to use a for loop for the alarms because
how do I sub on iPhone with the app?" Um, I actually don't know,
Caleb. I actually I have no idea actually how you do that to
be honest with you, but thank you. I appreciate it. I assume
there's a subscribe button, but interesting that it seems confusing.
I if anybody knows the answer to that, that'd be cool. So now
I said he didn't have to use for loops for the alarms, but this
one
you absolutely you're using 20 things.
>> it's something I've never even seen an amateur developer
do. It's also problematic in a few ways. Either the array should
be initialized the values directly then modified by using
>> uh not y Bob
completely ruining my friend Caleb's chance to individually sub.
You have totally his ability to individually sub. But thank you
for the gifted sub. I appreciate it buddy. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. We are currently five subs away from another hour.
Five subs. No. That's bad math, isn't it? No. No. That's right.
Six subs. Six subs from two more hours on stream. No. Seven subs
from two more hours on stream. Yes, there's that's where we are.
Yes, seven subs. Two more hours in the stream. Let's go, guys.
>> The right functions or we should be >> rude rude
streamer moment. Well, I'm just It's funny cuz it's like Yeah,
individual subs are the best. If you can individually sub, I
love when people individually sub because it's rolling income.
People can just let it go. But you know what? I still appreciate
the gift. Not y bo. Thank you very much. We appreciate you. using
a for loop iterating over the length of an existing array and
ensuring every index has a valid value if we're completely modifying
it to something else. Let's make our code change first then I'll
break it down. So
Marty with five gifted. Thank you very much Marty. Appreciate
you dude. Appreciate you. >> What I did here was I added
what is called the for loop. What this loop is doing is it will
start at the zero index of our array. Check to see if our current
index value is less than the total number of indices in our array.
Then it'll execute the lines inside the brackets. In our case,
aside oh, he's size of he's just doing for the whole Yeah, dude.
Golang's very nice for this. I do like Golang for this >> and
a value to the current index. Finally, it will increase our current.
I like any language that just says a decorator that if I'm doing
like a four with an array, that should be like it should be like
10 characters to do the iteration over the four next number and
check the loop conditions. Again, if the condition is still true,
it'll keep executing the code within the brackets until either
the condition isn't true or we explicitly break. >> Sophia,
thank gifted subs. That's two more hours on the stream. You love
to see it. Without even shilling, the audience comes through,
pushes the content further and further and further and further
and further. Thank you. >> Then after we finish with this
loop, we manually assign the two special index cases with the
angry road voice value. Loops are another basic concept of programming.
Now, why is this better? Well, for one thing, if we ever change
the size of the array code in the future, this code will still
be safe since the array length index will know the exact size
of the array. Also, not having to write a million lines of redundant
code is nice, too. Second, this is actually much safer and will
reduce the likelihood of runtime errors or what you as a player
would know as a game crash. So, what are runtime errors? Let's
say we have another place in code trying to use the voice list.
And let's say Jason thought he had 27 elements in his voice array
instead of 26. And he was once again using his magic numbers
to try and access index 27 of the road talk voice list. If we
look at the original array list, it only goes up to array index
26. So, what happens when you try to access an index that doesn't
exist? Oh no, segmentation
fault. You've accessed memory. You can't access that way. Okay.
Oh my god. >> Well, the game is going to crash. That's
what's going to happen. This happens because accessing an array
index isn't code Game Maker can verify ahead of time. So, what
happens is Game Maker will launch the game and execute the code
up to that point. Once it hits the invalid index, the program
will crash. Since only at that point in time will it know the
array index is invalid and there's no data there to access. Using
our approach and the array functions, we can guarantee the full
length of the array is accounted for and has values. We can also
use the array last function too where the last valid index of
an array. This doesn't guarantee the right character voice or
expression will be used. But I still think it's preferable to
have the wrong voice sound.
>> I don't like I don't like this, but >> while the
game is playing instead of having the game crashing and the player
losing who knows how much time or progress. Again, for loops
and default initialization are very beginner level concepts and
near universal in all programming languages. All right, last
snippet we're going to look at. This is like the next step beyond
hello world. I'd say his total lack of for loop usage. I didn't
know about this one. The one where he sets four alarms manually.
I was like, you know, he doesn't necessarily have to use a for
loop there. I get it. It's still totally readable. It's like
not actually that bad. We can deal with it. We can be okay. But
then this one with the with the voice list and and other stuff.
Oh my goodness. 20 24 elements getting set manually. That seems
pretty insane for this video. Here we have a gigantic switch
statement with multiple repeating cases and the total case amount
being like 1,000 cases for one possible branch path. There's
a second branch path where there's like another 100 switch cases
inside of two. I think Jason might be trolling us with this one.
Let's start with a simple improvement. Wait, what?
What is what for the multiple cases that are exactly the same
code? Normally when you have constantly repeating code, you write
a function and call it to reduce code duplication and to reduce
the possibility of incorrectly copying code introducing bugs
into your program. So if we create a function to reduce the amount
of repetition we do, there's a lot of benefits. First, it's a
lot easier to read and manage the code and the various cases.
Second, it reduces the possibility of doing something incorrectly
as honestly this is just what like most coding is. And if you
are incapable of figuring out where you can abstract out a function
and reuse it, I don't even know. I don't even know what the What
are you doing, man? If you're By the way, I've watched Chris
Bett lettuce do this a h 100 times. Okay, not actually a 100
times, but more than one time. Okay, Chris lettuce can do this
and he's been coding. He took one coding course and he's been
coding for like
months at tops, like like three months or something, right? So,
if Chris can do it, why can't Pirate Software do it is the question,
especially when you're doing the same step hundreds of times.
Again, better developer experience, too. If you have common behaviors
in a function, you don't need to manually type out the steps
for every common dialogue behavior. It also speeds up development
since Heartbound is a primarily story. By the way, yeah, Crisp
um that's not even like, if that sounds like a shot of Crisp
in any way, it's not. Crisp actually is Crisp has like some aptitude
for this, like unironically has some aptitude for it. Um, but
it like it's literally just going like, "Oh, I've noticed I've
done the same thing a couple times. How do I reuse this? How
do I redo this in the same way?"
>> Fat [__] Thank for the gifted sub. Let's
go. First gifted sub from Fat [__] You love to see
it. Let's go. Game. The more of these common functions you have,
the faster you can make cut scenes and dialogue scripts. Now,
how do we improve the 10,00 switch case? Well, I thought about
this for a while and I think the fastest way to improve it is
we take it and we throw it in the trash and never look at it
again. I generally thought about this for quite a while. There's
essentially no improving the structure. For most of these code
reviews, I tried to never recommend anything too far removed
from the current state of things, but this is generally such
horrifically architected code. There's basically no real way
to improve it without a complete rewrite of things.
I don't know. Like I'm thinking I'm thinking that this 999 there's
no way there's a thousand cases in this. I feel like it goes
to 999 because he's using as a special magic value again. Another
magic number, right? I feel like there's no way this actually
goes to 999 or something that can't >> when working with
dialogue or complex content using a lot more things than just
the raw strings themselves. An array of dialogue strcts for the
lines would be a fairly common approach and we could skim through
a quick example. So the struct data is pretty dependent on your
game and needs, but a few things are fairly common across most
games like having the line itself, the character you want to
show on screen and a dialogue type. Generally, we'll have the
event type dictate how to proceed. So, a more simple example
could be something like the following scenario. Here, we have
the dialogue array filled with strrus, and each dialogue line
is a strct in itself. And it tells us exactly what kind of dialog
event it is and what choice and actions are possible for it.
This reduces our switch theme to a handful of cases depending
on how many event types we end up having. Secondly, it provides
a very solid and reliable structure for us to use for all the
cut scenes. And do you think do you think Jason's gonna implement
some of this guy's suggestions? You'd hope so. By the way, this
is the first review that had an actual programmer. Um, I mean,
the Coding Jesus guy is like a programmer, but yeah, this guy
I don't even get the like I don't even get the idea that this
guy's like a um like a significantly experienced programmer.
He's suggesting things that are very smart that if you sat down
and were like, "Here's how I would do it. If you thought about
it, you should be able to come up with these things, right?"
Um, he's the first person I've listened to where I'm like, "You
know what? This guy doesn't suck. I I don't I don't really disagree
with this guy in >> within the game. Thought of some things
I didn't think of. Also, variables in Game Maker can point to
other scripts. So, let's say we needed to do something crazy
that requires an escape hatch. Well, that's also incredibly simple
since in Game Maker, we could set the value of the dialogue struck
to another script and call with script execute. With this, we
have reduced over a,000 dialogue cases into a handful that are
easier to reason about and extend. Since this is a separate example,
I'm not going to dive into this anymore. Okay, with all that
out of the way, I think we can start closing up. Uh, Drewie,
I am very much of your mindset. I am very much of your mindset.
Unfortunately, Pirate Software has turned his game into like
his he's like literally a solo developer in developer hell. He
is so bad at writing understandable code that he cannot actually
ship code. Even though he is the only developer on this code,
he is not shipping the code. He is not shipping the code. Let
me repeat, he is not shipping the code. Okay, this game is not
shipped. This game is so far behind schedule that most people
who initially backed it are actually dead. Okay, every single
person who backed this on Patreon is actually dead now. Just
kidding. It's been like five. It's been like 10 years, but not
actually dead, but it's been forever. Okay. Sisphus the developer.
Yeah, he just is like he's not a coder and he's just clearly
it's it's a problem. The code review and I can start going over
my comments. First off, yes, there's a lot more things wrong
with the code I've shown from Jason that I didn't talk about.
There were way too many. I dude, this video is way better in
terms of picking out actual problems and solving them. This guy's
video was sick. That's why I I will give it a like thanks to
Nitpick. So, I try to limit my comments to the biggest issues.
I also tried to avoid offering changes or advice that is too
far detached from his current structure and setup. That's why
I didn't run through multiple solutions. Also, I didn't talk
about any actual game design patterns since that would be another
video into itself and he wasn't actually using any inside his
code. Next, during the code reviews, I wasn't explaining any
special concepts or anything. All of the boolean stuff, the for
loops, the safe default initialization, using functions with
parameters, enums or con stuff, all of that is literally introlevel
program concepts. There was at no point in the code reviews where
I went above a junior level developer's expected knowledge. Well,
except maybe >> the strruct iteration. No, I mean, realistically,
it looked like this guy just went through and like figured out.
>> No, the strruct iteration should be
I'd say if this is just like
This is just the same as like a strruct is a dictionary, right?
The strruct a strruct is a dictionary.
There should be some way to go through this even if it's like
a little different. But yeah, the rest of this I would say the
only thing that seemed maybe a little is the pointer to other
scripts. That was maybe something where like the the pointer
to other scripts. Yeah, I think that's a little spooky. >> The
duration and the save file >> spooky for like somebody
that that that might not be something a junior developer would
do.
This is kind of potentially hacky. >> To help put this
in perspective, let's pull up the Stanford CS 106A intro to programming
course. This is a first year first semester type of course. is
incredibly similar to the one I took during my first year of
college. And let's just look at the things you learn in it. Basically,
everything I discussed in this video is stuff you learn in this
intro level course. The fact Jason doesn't even seem to have
a good understanding or >> This is why I said, "Dude, I
I'm telling you, Chris Bettis is a better programmer than Thor."
Like, 100% he is. It's not even close. It's not even like a question.
I'm positive Chris Bett lettuce could be could build a better
game in Game Maker. >> Know about some of these things.
It's just baffling. If we consider his 2002 LinkedIn start date
as when he started learning about programming, that means as
of today in 2025, he has 23 years of experience programming.
Yet somehow he doesn't even seem to understand the most basic
entry-level concepts in programming. It doesn't matter what program
languages you use or learned. These concepts like loops and booleans
are essentially universal in nearly all languages. Now, someone
might argue he doesn't have 20 years of GameMaker experience.
I don't think that's a valid argument, but let's go through it
anyways. his first release. >> Sorry, I'm saying I am saying
that if you're going to define a static a static dictionary,
which is what he's doing, right? He's he's defining at compile
time. Demiurge, right? He's literally writing this out as like
a static list of scenes. So, I'm saying a strruct I should have
said like an immutable dict or something. It's like an immutable
dict and that is a strct the same thing, right? Keys
cuz it seems like he is he is literally just using one instance
of the strct. It's not like he's reusing the strruct. This guy
suggested using the strct instruct iteration because why? Because
it just made things more readable.
Am I crazy? Because at different places in the strct, he like
nests and then it's just arrays of integers. I think I'm I'm
thinking I'm not I'm not That's not my fault though. That's not
your fault though. That's my fault. I'm not actually communicating
very well what I'm thinking. Uh probably from being out of programming
for like 2 years. The game was Champions of Breakfast and he
spent roughly 8 to nine months on it. So, for Heartbound, he
should have had a pretty good understanding of things. If I wasn't
making this video, I probably never would have touched GameMaker
in my entire life. The entire time it took me to grasp the Game
Maker language and write the code you saw in this video was roughly
2 and 1/2 hours. So, I'm not giving Jason any passes due to a
lack of experience with Game Maker. Now, I avoided trash talkinging
his code too much during the reviews, but let me pull up that
Mega Switch statement again. Let me also pull up some Yandere
Death Code. Now, I know everyone trash talks Yandere Dev's code,
but it's easy to see how and why he made this. He had zero previous
gamedev experience or programming experience and he dived head
first into Unity. He just took the first thing he learned and
he ran with it for every problem. The code isn't good by any
means, but you can understand why it's like that. With Jason,
I'm just left so confused. Like, he's supposed to be a gamedev
industry veteran and yet he's making stuff as bad as a complete
amateur like Yandere Dev. I also spent some time after finishing
up this portion of the video thinking back to all the code reviews
I've done in all my previous jobs. I've easily done somewhere
in the thousands of various code reviews. And I've reviewed code
from all sorts of experience levels from senior software architects
to people having done a fourmon boot camp and having less than
half a years of >> bro I don't think I've ever done an
email based review. Somebody just emails me code is like you
can you review this. I don't think I've ever done that before.
Ad hoc review formal inspe I don't even know. I guess formal
inspection is kind of self-explanatory
>> anyway experience. And yet I don't think I've ever reviewed
anyone's code that was this bad. I'm not being hyperbolic when
I say this but this is generally some of the worst code I've
ever reviewed. And I didn't even explain or like dive into every
possible issue with it. Plus, if we remember all of Jason's hacking
claims, guess what? You need to know these basic program concepts
if you want to do reverse engineering or malware analysis. This
is the foundation nearly everything else builds off of. Taking
all that into account, I think Jason has been lying through his
teeth about all his coding abilities, all his assembly stories,
and just making stuff up with terms he's heard thrown around.
If I was working with Jason and I saw this type of code being
repeatedly submitted, I would push for him to be fired with my
state of reason being gross incompetence.
Gross. Not even just incompetence. Okay, you are disgustingly
incompetent. My god. This does explain the clip where he calls
programmers wizards, dude. Yes. Oh my god. Hold on. Hold on.
Pirate software YouTube maxim. Where's Maximus langu? Uh short
shorts.
YouTube short
uh programming. Yes. Yes. Understand something as a programmer.
Every language is all of them are. They're all bad. And that's
why we use so many of them because they're bad. We're just a
bunch of wizards with weirdass spells that sometimes work. We
perform magic. Sometimes that magic goes wrong. Sometimes we
don't know why. Sometimes we do know why. Sometimes it goes right.
Sometimes we don't know why. Sometimes we do know why. And that's
just how it works. Understand something as a programmer. Every
language.
>> It's unbelievable, dude. It's
Okay. Does the Wii give you stolen valor outrage? Not really.
Well, maybe a little bit. It's like, dude, just
>> no. You know, okay, with 20 years of experience or even
like 5 to 10 years of experience, it's not like that. It's not
like that at all. It's not. You're not. We're not casting spells.
We know what we're doing. It's very calculated thing. Can you
explain why this is so stupid to say? Um, I don't know. I've
just written code for a long time and I've never gotten to the
place where I'm like but I I don't know. I guess I walk through
code pretty well in my head. I'm not Yeah, I'm not like guessing.
I'm not um I'm just like trying a bunch of things unless I'm
working on very old code that I'm trying to fix somebody else's
very old code and then maybe it's like, okay, I don't really
know what's going on. I have to figure out what was going on
here, what they're trying to do. I run into stuff like that.
>> Yeah. Anyway,
All right. Uh,
okay. Um,
where are we going next? Okay. So, that was all to set up his
defenses for his coding. Okay. In his Discord where he kind of
rages out pretty significantly about coding Jesus, coding Jesus's
reviews, and there's a 4chan thing at the beginning. Okay. This
this post gets made on 4chan and he decides to get a crash out
in his Discord about it. Popular transgender gamedev/streamer
bullied to by Reddit. Jason Thor Hall known online as pirate
software has tragically lost his battle with depression this
morning. He was celebrated for his informative programming Tik
Toks and captivating Twitch streams. However, his outspoken opinions
on the stop games initiative sparked significant controversy,
leading to relentless bullying, harassment, death threats, and
even swatting incidents. Jason is fondly remembered by his Twitch
and gay furry by his Twitch community and gay furry community.
Predators harassed some guy to death even before because he disagreed
with them. But because of his deep voice, in a way, he's kind
of smart for using a voice changer to deepen his voice to make
himself seem more credible.
On the other hand, when he was invariably caught out for doing
so, after people found videos of him speaking with his normal
voice, he responded with, "Um, I had second puberty. That made
my voice super deep." Which means he's clearly a and probably
got the idea to use a voice changer from someone else or from
a TV show or something. Jason is dead. Stop teasing me like that.
Die, furler, that'd be funny. You misrepresented the intentions
of the movement. Okay, what did he say, though? Well, he said
some things. Not a joke. Please say psych. Not a joke. They come
after me all the time.
Today, 4chan tried to say I committed while saying it's because
I'm trans. Actually, they said it's because of relentless bullying,
harassment, and death threats, and even swatting incidents, right?
Like like they they don't say it's like they say you are trans,
but they they say the harassment is why you yourself. They don't
say it's cuz you're trans. They just say also, as an aside, he's
a beloved trans influencer. Anyway, all because I'm
Is it still as bad as it was in this in the height of the hate
train? I heard the band numbers something. Yep. Since they couldn't
kill me with swatting, they went after our business in other
ways. Hit the sponsors, offbrand the moderators, our rescue,
anything they could find. All in the name of valid criticism.
Oh. Uh, he had to step down from off-brand games. He said, so
I didn't follow this one, but he said it was because he's stepping
down from off-brand because they were getting review bombs on
their games. But they weren't getting review bombs on their games.
if you looked into it, right?
>> Uh, cool. Hellbent, I'm glad I'm glad we got the update
from you. Thank you. All right.
Um, yeah. So, I think he he got asked to leave off brandand or
he left off brandand. He said it was because of review bombing.
I think they were just like, "Hey, man. You're going through
some stuff. Could you get the out of here? Get the out. Would
he even do it offbrand?" He was like a creative director or something.
I think uh Thor off-brand studios. Let's see if we can just get
an article that explains it or something. Thor just got hired
as director of strategy. Oh, hold on. What did it say here? Thor
just got hired as on as their director of strategy. Any word
on how they will be different from vampires here? Pirate Software,
dude. Sports Illustrated. What the Why is Sports Illustrated,
dude? Everybody's getting in on Pirate Software's death. So much
so that Sports Illustrated is publishing publishing articles
on the guy. The pirate software leaves off-brand games as stop
games reaches goal. Following an unpopular opinion on the initiative,
the streamer has decided to distance himself from the company
to avoid negative press being attributed to the wrong people.
So, this all got said, he said, "Oh yeah, they've reviewbombed
it, right? I am no longer working at off-brand games." Actually,
let's go to the tweet. I am no longer working at off-brand games.
People were attacking all of the games we were publishing and
trying to mass review bomb them. You can dislike the things I
say, but this behavior kind of behavior is unhinged. learned
a lot there, accomplished a lot. Hope they succeed regardless.
Love the dudes and love working with them. Hope they keep cooking.
For those trying to say this is somehow a lie. This the next
day. No, it's a little bit later. 4 hours later.
>> The abuse was across socials, people on Discord, Twitter,
Reddit, and some reviews on Steam. So, it's not review bombing
anymore. It's just a couple reviews. Indie games are fragile
things, and attacks like that hit hard. Overall sentiment was
to try to bash the games and the developers working on them to
try to get back at me. Not worth bringing them down for my opinion.
Also, stop it. Get some help. Thank you, Michael Jordan. Thank
you, Michael Jordan. I wonder if there was a post from anybody
who who said, you know, basically how this was a lie. Oh, you
unblocked me. You're a goddamn liar.
There's been no review bombs and you're upset about Reddit post
that got deleted. You're a You're a spineless, pathetic furry
that without the internet and nepotism would have never received
any attention or praise in life. >> Well, that seems like
a reasonable take. So, this is um Aetherman
doesn't seem like doesn't seem like the very positive reviews.
Yeah, it's
>> recent reviews very positive. Yeah. So, Aetherman is
fine. And then uh frog uh body bear saves frog time. No review
And then
Rivals of Aether 2. Maybe you could argue, is this review bombing?
No, it's like positive. It's like almost mostly positive. And
it seems like it's pretty consistent through the whole month.
And it had some pretty bad reviews right off the bat when it
got released. So, I don't know. It doesn't This guy seems pretty
valid. The Solidest Guy doesn't seem like it got review bombed
at all. Seems like he was maybe asked to leave or I'm not even
sure. But the review bombing thing was just made up. And he does
this for some reason. Okay.
He's almost got a little bit of tom foolery in him. Does it?
Doesn't he? He just kind of like adds things for no reason. That
like it wouldn't even matter if he didn't include it. Lwig claimed
rivals got bombed. It didn't. Yeah, it it didn't.
They're just lying. Why? He didn't have to include that detail.
He could just say, "Hey, I'm no longer working at off brandand
games. I'm getting like I'm having a lot of stress because I
I get the impression that people will start attacking things
I'm associated with so I'm going to leave then nobody can even
no that's just you saying here's my state of mind and why I'm
leaving right that's all you got to do but instead he says oh
it's getting stuff's getting review bombed and then you give
a fact for people to check you shouldn't give a fact for people
to check you should just go and do your thing go and do your
thing bro
is hair Tom Fery doesn't what's up moody Morgan oh thank you
for the kind words yeah I know Um, I know Cherry made a tweet.
I just feel like it's weird for me to draw attention to it or
try to like people
um, as far as that tweet goes, it's like I think probably people
who wanted to see something good in me will say, "Oh, that absolves."
And people who didn't like me are going to say it means nothing.
And there probably aren't a lot of people, a ton of people in
the middle. Um, I wouldn't expect it to change like a lot of,
you know, critical people's opinions. Uh, yeah. Well, I've gotten
a bunch of messages about it, so I'm I said I'm not going to
read it anyway.
Anyway, we go back to the pirate software stuff. We go back to
the pirate software stuff.
where do we go? We've got this. Oh, now we can finally go back.
Okay, we can finally go back to this stuff. How do we even get
onto off-brand? How do we get onto that? Now I forget. Oh, went
after our businesses sponsors offbrand. The moderators arrest
you anything they can find. All they have a valid criticism.
I think honestly it's people who just hate you at this point.
Like I support stop games and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Your perspective changes when they try to murder you. I legit
don't give a single person who has criticized Thor is participating
in the attempts to murder him. Okay, this was the technique we
saw many many many times throughout all of his controversies
is he will take the absolute worst actors, the tiniest tiniest
tiniest percentage of people who do up things and he will say,
"Yeah, the person who who says like me defending my coding or
or lying about people who criticize my coding or lying about
stop games, those people are all participating in a culture that's
attempting to murder me."
>> Throw a group on 4chan. He's obviously tempered. I doesn't
seem tempered. Okay. Seems very fragile.
very very fragile.
>> Was going through this dude's videos. He about my code
in Heartbound. I think this was the Oh, do I have this slightly
out of order? I might This one might be slightly out of order.
The com This be the This will be the guy the coding Jesus guy.
Okay. >> Um anyway, he talks about it. Yikes. And I'm certain
the comments are full of people agreeing with him even if they
know better. I I've up my imager album for this a little bit.
We'll see if I go down. Maybe it'll be the coding Jesus
Oh, this is him talking about review bombing. I think this screenshot's
out of order. Like pretty out of order. Uh, I enjoy working on
the game. Did not enjoy dealing with this every day. Oh, so they're
so their support forum had things making fun of um
Oh, this is Wait, this is Heartbound. Heartbound needs more updates.
You going to finish the game, Jason? Holy Topic locks Batman.
Make great make games great again. Almost seven years early access.
Oh, not to mention sales have doubled/ tripled over normal as
people buy the game to leave negative reviews and refund their
purchase. Okay, that's people are probably reviewing or review
bombing Heartbound. That's probably true. That's probably true.
>> Okay, this is going to the Coding Jesus video. I think
it's a little out of order from before. He literally just makes
up. Lol.
I don't think he made anything up. I don't think his I don't
think his code review was very good. Certainly not as good as
the second one we watched, but I don't think he made anything
up. Thor shows his comment. Have a laugh. Thor shows his comment
again. Was going through the dude's video as he about my code
in Heartbound. Everything he complains about is standard to Game
Maker. Lol. He doesn't even define a boolean data type. Game
Maker doesn't have you define booleans. I mean, you have booleans
and you can use true or false. You can use zero or one or true
or false at will. Data types don't need to be defined. This is
reaching peak insanity. So, it's a dynamically typed language.
And the guy is saying he's saying you should use bulls. The bulls
in the game, the the duct typed bulls in the game where if you
use true or false, it's a constant and it will automatically
do that thing.
>> Uh um random. Uh send me the tweets Blumpkins if that's
what you Jesus. Let me read this. Um random. Have you seen Dan's
Dan on Twitter in the last few hours? Someone is stating that
Willyax fans and Dan seem to align.
Dan threatened to show photos of the guy's basement. Not wanting
to derail. Apologies. Um, random. Oh, not wanting to derail.
I've not seen that,
dude. I Maybe that happened. I don't know if that happened, but
yeah, Dan's always been very clear. He loves doxing people. If
you talk about him, he will dox you. He's made it very very very
clear like a hundred different times that he doxes people and
he doesn't care. It's fine. Well, it's not really fine, but it
it is what it is. It is what it is. Okay, I shouldn't say it's
fine. It's probably not fine, but it is what it is. It is what
it is. Okay, this pirates uh game he or sorry, his comment on
the on the coding Jesus video, which is also kind of a arguments.
My god, they can't read either. LMFAO,
if your ARG is solvable with access to the source code, how is
it an ARG? It's not. That's part of the process for people solving
it. Go read the write up made by the community. Idiots. Idiots.
>> So, the DRM guy had a good reason for why that was cope,
right? He was like, "Oh, it's just about how the save file is
handled, right? Maybe not. Maybe I will have to look more into
it." Oh, dude. The This is one of the comments that he's making
fun of. Dude, the issue isn't about the alarms or if sprite spark
is a magic number. The issue is you have a giant incomprehensible
array for every story event in the game. This is the definition
of an anti pattern. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's a That's
a valid comment. That's a good comment.
He's downvoting the individual comments on the video. Did you
notice this? These are his screenshots. He's actually downvoting
the individual comments on the coding Jesus video. You man, you
the array for the save file is to create a workabella structure
for reverse engineers trying to solve the energy behind the game.
It also saved this out in the exact same order in the in the
save file. Yeah. So, I think this is why he's saying in the strruct
it's like, okay, a workable structure. It's like, okay, that
>> I think a far more workable structure, especially if
you're trying to make the structure intentful,
>> is probably the actual strct where you can where you
can lay things out directly where you can have it like statically
defined because those things shouldn't update that often, right?
You don't need that to be in a dynamically fulfilling fulfilled
structure.
>> Anyway, halfway into the video and he's nagging about
not defining values as constant and then passing that to the
class. Like I'm but a lowly Python dev. But wouldn't that cause
even more spaghetti code?
Think about not defining values as constant and then passing
that to the class.
No. Why? Especially when functions I'm calling are built-ins.
This is what? This is a weird comment. I don't know why that
would make more spaghetti code. That's very odd.
like I didn't write those functions. I think this is he's glomming
onto this criticism because this is the one that's like defensible,
right? You call them to modify an existing particle emitter.
This way you can change effects dynamically. Yeah, I don't think
the particle stuff is different. I I I don't think the particle
stuff the magic numbers there are like a good criticism. We keep
looking.
>> Maybe spent more time reviewing his own code rather
than other people's. He might learn where he went wrong. I just
don't understand the
like I I can defend his code in like ways where I know I'm probably
wrong, but I'm like you aren't making good criticism. So, I'm
kind of attacking your criticism cuz it's less boring than just
going after him and saying he's a total, right? But realistically,
he kind of is a total his code is pretty
I don't know why he's so about it. Why you got to be so insanely
about it, bro? You're like crazy about this and I don't understand
why. I sent a DM via X for the link. Are you sure? I don't see
any DM here. So unlucky. Hold on. That might be Wait a second.
X can be really annoying. Um if I'm behind a VPN.
Let me see. Yeah, I don't have anything on X. You sent me something
on X. I ain't got it, bro. Sorry. Just send it on Discord.
I think they were just saying it doesn't make sense to declare
variables like a equals 1, b equals false and just pass it into
a function.
Um, they're saying declaring const and then passing into a function
doesn't make sense. If they if they were saying that that wouldn't
be true, but the idea of doing the const would be that you want
to you want to know what that is. But I would say for IDE builtins,
okay, for sorry for Game Maker builtins where you're going to
use the GameMaker IDE, you probably don't need to name those
numbers. Those magic numbers are going to be fine. That person
is not Cherry. Shut up. Okay, we continue through these logs.
Imagine if it this wasn't a coding language, but a spoken one.
You're speaking Chinese wrong. This Nope, dude. What? What? That's
an insane uh that maybe reveals his his total lack of understanding
of code directly. Cuz what we're actually saying here is
>> is like you are
speaking with like an incomprehensible lisp. You're like speaking
English, but you have your tongue cut off, right? Yeah. You might
not be speaking Chinese wrong necessarily, but unfortunately
it's incomprehensible to everybody else and it doesn't really
get the job done. Game Maker uses GameMaker language. Cool. GML
works this way. No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. You don't have
to do a single dimensional array. The the guy the slop news network
guy proved that. Okay. Remember kids, don't comment your code.
It makes baby Jesus cry. Ah, this is my thoughts as well. I like
I like self-documented code. I like code that I don't need to
write. That's the whole point of using in a lot of cases the
constants or writing things like if he couldn't write comments
he would have to via the code via the names of his variables
and stuff be telling the story of what his code means right his
over reliance on comments is what leads to his code overall his
code is because of his over reliance on comments what's up moral
how's it going
>> you get banned from the discord again
updated my post on it
hasn't moved but this community's on it. Oh, are they letting
your comment stay or have they deleted it? H haven't moved but
his community's on it. Let's see. Posts a comment. People laugh.
Absolute zazzle. What's the What's this? Surely if you are if
you're the one who created the ARG, you can explain it here.
Why would an ARG require several hundred lines of hardcoded hardcoded
dialogue tree options at Big Boss? What? Those are not dialogue
tree options. They are save states for individual objects around
the game. things like choices made by the player that impact
the story line. Okay, so again, why oh why oh why oh why would
that need to be in a hard-coded or sorry in a hard-coded array?
That doesn't that's not an answer. Things like choices made by
the player. Uh keeping this this structure allows people to modify
it easily both in memory and in the save file. Okay,
so you just need something that keeps it in contiguous in memory.
So the the goal here and if you're a 25-y year veteran of programming,
this should be something you can understand and solve. Okay,
how do I keep this contiguous in memory and in its save file
output? How do I keep the same structure in memory and in the
save file output so that it can be modified by people to participate
in some ARG or to hack the game in some way? Can I do I have
to use an array or can I do that with some other structure? That
should be very easy, very understandable. Only like two more
days and then I'll be back. Okay, well good luck, bro. I know
you can make it. I didn't even read the rest of his comment.
All of those values are saved out in order, which makes it simple
for people with technical or nontechnical knowledge to modify
them. This lets them change several values at many different
times in the RG to progress. Yeah. Again, this was the iterating
through the strct thing where it's like if it's just for the
save file for non-technical people, you can iterate through a
strct with no issues. Easy. I'm thinking they don't understand
the ARG side. Of course, they don't. They follow this for programming
advice.
Oh, dude. I don't know how he would handle
This video, dude, this video is actually so much better. This
video is like this video is like a shot video. Like literally
him explaining how you would do this in assembly and how his
experience of assembly, which is bad,
right? And he doesn't really know anything. And he's explaining
why why Pirate Software's DRM wouldn't do anything against somebody
who understands any of these concepts and how that proves that
Pirate Software himself probably doesn't understand these concepts.
That's a way better video, right? Pirate Software will not acknowledge
this video, will he? We won't see a Pirate Software comment on
this video. This video is too good for him to comment on the
coding Jesus video. That was a flub. This video, this is real
[__] All right. This is absolutely real. You love
to see it.
>> All right. He posts more comments here. More comments
here. Yeah. Like I see a way of Oh, sorry. Show me code that
makes is a perfect example. What?
Like Yeah, I see a way of doing it. And you probably have another
idea in mind. Some of these things are like universally my idea
is better than your idea. That's the issue, right?
>> Oh, it's Gat Fumodor. Oh, Dan would dox Gatof Fumador
anyway.
Dan wouldn't care about doxing Gatof Fumodor. Yeah, Dan's going
to go after that guy no matter what. Unfortunate. It's less It's
less so that annoy anything is wrong. It's more so that I was
the one who wrote the code. These people, These people are just
idiots. No. See, he's doing it again. He's done it again, guys.
He's actually done it again. Okay, he's taken a case where, hey,
you don't even have to eat the unreasonable criticism, but he
doesn't know the difference between reasonable and unreasonable.
He thinks he's correct on everything despite being a and he is
going to double down on him being right and everyone else being
wrong. And then he'll think, "Oh, it's the whole world just hating
me as a person instead of, oh, I'm wrong on these things. I'm
wrong on many things."
>> Pretty sure Gat Fumodor is a is a black lady. Oh, Jesus.
Well, she shouldn't get Doxen at all. >> Gucci Jesus. Speaking
of Gucci Jesus, thank you for the two months. Brand new individual
sub over on kick. Let's go. Thank you very much, Gucci Jesus,
for the sub. Solid subday. Solid individual subday over here.
See here. I need to reset the meters as well. I'll do that in
just a second. Let's look at some of these comments he's making
fun of. Oh, this is going to be hard to show the whole thing
on stream. You guys aren't going to see it. I'll just read. Oh,
here. Hold on. I'll zoom in on this one, though. How is someone
nontechnical going to make massive uh change a massive array
saved in a file? Is he going to have another file telling him?
Oh, so this would be he'd have some probably some code for saving
for outputting the file, right? Outputting the save file. Save
states. You mean flags that are flipped after certain dialogue
options are selected in the game, thus setting the flag so it
can be checked later. You can see your own com comments in the
video. Jim blah blah blah blah. Is that flag not referencing
a dialogue the player triggered? Ah, how is it easy to modify
something if you have to constantly look up several hundred different
flags
and like what they mean? Yeah, it's only in comments. It's the
massive issue. You don't have to constantly look up several hundred
flags. Do you read the entire dictionary to find the word you're
looking for? No, cuz it's in alphabetical order, but you have
no actual ordering to this. It's just a bunch of numbers. It's
like literally if you if you ordered a dictionary, if you randomize
the dictionary, assign every word a number, and then we're like,
well, you have things trouble looking up things in the dictionary.
Yes. Now I do have trouble looking up things in the dictionary.
Now it's very difficult.
Idiot. What is he? What is this? Now it's probably not quite
that bad cuz I'm guessing he sort of remembers. He probably had
like a general structure laid out or something and then eventually
he's like adding things in. I'm sure he came to some place where
it's like somewhat explicable. But he's got like 500 things in
there. It's going to fade over time. You mean you mean to tell
me you don't know what 264 points to? Huh? I don't. Uh so somebody
asked something else. Oh, this guy up here. It was a puzzle for
the community to solve what each index did. Some puzzles let
them know which index to change. Some had some they had to figure
out. They've solved all the steps thus far over the last several
years built communities around it. Oh, okay. Wow. Big Boss responds
to Pirate Software. So, you're saying a player going to the gym
and talking at a uh talking at a bench press is not a very specific
situation. All we understand that the code uh that the code is
used to build a personal decision profile for every player. We're
saying that it's done poorly at a point which you still haven't
contended with other than saying it's for the ARG. The the point
isn't about it being lightweight but about uh but about being
readable and easily referenced and
uh and he asks him again, why not use the enims for the intimate
systems of the game and then offiscate that using a wrapper data
type so that players solving the ARG can just reference that
instead. This is very basic programming pattern. This is a very
basic programming pattern. It appears my last comment was eaten
by the void. Enums are used in many systems throughout the game
where they are appropriate. The system is the only one that doesn't
use them as it adds nothing based on implementation. It adds
readability. It's literally he's saying your code is because
you literally probably have to go back and forth between this
file and read comments instead of just looking at the number
and saying, "Oh, that's where it goes." It's
Could I build it differently? Sure. Would it impact the ARG solvers?
Absolutely. An enum would not would not impact the ARG solvers
at all. An enum would explicitly not even change anything else.
Uh the the slop what is it? Slop news network. This guy had a
better solution obviously but even just the enum solution would
make this infinitely more readable, infinitely easier for him
to actually go back and forth programming on. Apparently you
have to guarantee arrays to guarantee memory order in Game Maker.
Strrux don't guarantee that. Oh, okay. Well, then that would
be fine. But then you still need the enim and the enum is just
a wrapped integer. In the same way that he he can't argue that
I don't have to use the boolean data type because it's the same
and then argue I shouldn't use an enum for this because it's
different. You can't do both of those arguments. Those arguments
conflict completely. Okay, an enum is just going to be a number,
right? It's going to go in that array
is very easy to understand. There's zero reason not there's zero
reason to avoid using an enum there anyway. There is no benefit
in refactoring the system as such. You can be upset about it,
but people solving that portion of the game are thankful for
it.
Enum. You don't like me saying enume? Why? Wait, why? Why do
you guys think it's enum?
What is What is enum short for?
You guys know enum. You know, enum is short for something, right?
So, you should say
>> No, it's not enum. It's not an enumerated type. It's
an enumerated
>> It's not an enumerated type. It's not an enumerated
type. It's an enumerated type. Enume.
>> People going crazy.
>> I'm sure this is good content for people who don't understand
programming. I'm sure there are a lot of non-programmers in here
who are digging this awesome content. Okay. Anyway, at Pirate
Software, you could still hide it using enums. The enims wouldn't
be written to the save file. You'd only use them as indexes.
Yeah, indices for what the storyline variables mean. You have
their meanings commented already. If you wanted to add some puzzle
while still being able to flash it on screen and set the enum
to something they wouldn't suspect uh and set the and set the
enum to something they wouldn't expect. Okay. Isn't that something
you do in puzzles anyway and would comment on uh comment it too?
So instead of a comment, you'd have an enum explaining what is
in the index. So this guy's asking for an enum for each state,
which is kind of the same thing. Yeah, you could use an enum
for each state as well. They would then have a harder time changing
values in runtime as there would be two systems.
What? No, they wouldn't. No, they would not. No, they would not.
No, they would not. No, there would not. No, there would not.
No, there would not. Creating a simple array keeps He's not asking
you not to make an array. Effectively, your solution makes reodification
harder, which is what I don't want. It doesn't make remodification
harder. It doesn't do any of this.
>> What?
Oh, he actually this is actually significantly worse than everything
else are these comments. He doesn't even understand what the
guy's suggesting. I see enum and SQL just to
wait. Why wouldn't you say SQL? Everyone says SQL. What do you
mean I say SQL to trigger people?
What? Oh, hold on. Dolce Bellum in expertise is going to disagree
with me on this one. I see SQL structured query language. Nah,
I'm a big fan of saying it as a word. Nah, nah nah nah. Sequel.
Sequel. Sequel.
Sequel. True. Two syllables instead of three. Obviously, Billy
Billy Joe Bouche has won the argument. Two syllables instead
of three. We say sequel. We say sequel in this house. Okay. Every
accountant on Earth calls it sequel. Okay. Based. I don't care
who else calls it sequel. I just like sequel. Do we get anything
else? This really isn't a big deal for the game and doesn't impact
development. Yeah, it does. Bad practice has a purpose when you
do it when you have a reason to do it. I feel like, dude, I feel
like somebody walked past him when he had this this array at
like 90 and was like, "Hey, that's a really bad pattern." He's
like, "No, it's for the ARG." And he's like had to continue that
excuse for the rest of time. Like he actually he he actually
knows that it's bad practice, but he he like didn't know it at
the time and he like gave somebody an excuse. I don't know.
He's literally saying things that don't make any sense. Now,
I will say the struck thing that the guy suggested, if you can't
guarantee the order of strus in memory, if there's not a consistent
way of of forming those in memory, dude, am I the only person
who like looks at this, by the way, and I'm like, "Oh, Protobuff
would solve this." Protocol buffers would solve this. Protobuff,
Protobuff, Protobuff, I'm the only person, right? Cuz I think
the thing about Protobuff is I think it has a guarantee that
when it's serialized, right, when it's serialized, that if any
two structures that are equivalent when they're serialized will
be equivalent no matter what. Anyway, you don't even need proto.
I'm just like I'm like, "Oh, it save it solves the the issue."
To be honest, you can solve the issue yourself without any need
for any additional abstractions. But he's on the side of self-explaining
code. Oh, this going back to coding Jesus. He's on the side of
self-explaining code, which is dog practice. Explain your code
for those who come after. No, no, no, no,
no.
Now, I'm not somebody who says you can't use comments.
I'm not somebody who says you can't use comments, but I absolutely
like comments should be rare at best. >> Okay, I don't
know. I would love to see a developer who agrees with this. Like
a an actual senior developer who agrees with actually self-explanating
code is dog practice.
>> Maybe you could argue it's dog practice if you're like
writing assembly or if you're like writing assembly or like cobalt
or something. Maybe then I don't know like maybe you can't build
abstractions that are explainable enough or understandable enough
that you but like in Python or something or in like a bunch of
other languages almost any modern language at all.
>> Bro, you have you have structures there that you can
you make things very human
>> Self-explaining code is only is only use is only use
when only you touch the code now and later. Right? No,
it's just more attempts at undermining me as a person. None of
these are Dude, now he's just arguing for garbage. He's actually
just arguing for garbage right now. It's very interesting. Like
like to say that oh actually self-documenting code is dog
What is he talking about? Is there actually a coherent argument
against the concept of self-documenting code?
Is there a single coherent argument against
self-documenting code? My code is self-explanatory. It's one
of those low IQ, high IQ takes. Coders use it as excuse. I'm
sure maybe.
>> I guess you could say that people, dumb people could
use it as a reason to not actually explain what they're doing
or make things clear. But that just seems Dude, you don't you
don't like uh baby proof stuff. You don't say, "Oh, well, really
dumb people might interact with this, so we're going to make
rules for them." Why would you do that? Hammers wouldn't exist.
Hey, actually a could hit themselves in the head with that hammer.
So, you should get rid of it. Get rid of it. It's actually really
bad for all of us. No, this a tool. No, thank you. Comments are
good. Actually, comments are fine. I don't hate comments. If
you want to write comments, but like you shouldn't comment every
line and you should you comment in situations where a comment
is required. Like, all you have to do is go look at where was
it? Here. He has a comment here where he's like talking through
something on stream, right? Hold on. Let me let me go see this.
Let me see if I can find in the transcript here. Comments, comments,
comments, comments.
Not this one. Not this one. It's not that one either because
that you could say is required explanation.
>> This one. This is the one right here where it's like
we have we have asked the question. Question asked equals one.
>> What's the point of naming the variable question asked?
Why not name it Q if you're going to do this? It's like so the
idea of doing it in code is because then if you re if you decide
you want to refactor the name question asked to something else
it's more accurate. You just use the code refactor tool and it
refactors everything as opposed to this comment which you can't
refactor.
>> back to this
more attempts at undermining me as a person. None of these arguments
are in good faith. A year ago, people would ask me why I did
this and then say that's cool. Now it's the subject of video
on me. Self-explaining code is only Oh yeah, sure. I'm the only
one using this code and I still comment it so I know what it
does in 3 months. I mean I So here's what I do. Actually, this
is unironically a process I use all the time. Okay, if I'm going
to write some API, okay, typical three- layer architecture, API
layer, um API layer, domain layer or uh what we call this like
server layer or something like logic layer and then a a domain,
sorry, a repository layer, something that interacts with like
a database or outside anything else, right?
I I would probably go I would start at like an API layer. I'd
make like a I'd make um like the API stub and then I'd use comments
to say this is how I'm going to structure. I love structuring
up my code. I love scaffolding up my code. Right? That's what
I use comments for is to scaffold out my code and say, okay,
I'm going to like call this API, then I'm going to modify data
in this way, then I'm going to call this other API, then I'm
going to save it over here, right? That's what I'll do at like
a high level. And that's that's broadly the way I'll write code
is I'll I'll comment first and just say this is my plan to do
things, right? Yeah. But then I I erase those and I make a a
function that like basically accurately reflects what the code
says it does or the comment says it's going to do.
application data presentation. Uh I'm talking about a backend
architecture but >> I'm talking about like just at a at
a server three level three layer architecture to server layer
server level um like a backend level.
>> I don't know why I even said that. I was like going
to go through a more more complex explanation then I'm like oh
wait actually people I actually don't need to do that people
that's like way too way too complex for stream. Um no reason
people would need to know it.
Okay. How does he keep doing? He's on the dog side. That's such
a ridiculous practice. It just makes me think that the guy never
act held an actual position in a corporate environment where
cooperation understanding is
it would be essential. Here's here's the actual take. If you've
if you've ever coded in your life, the reason you don't comment
your code a ton is because everybody if everybody's touching
a code path, if like two different teams or three different teams
with like five people each, you know, 10 15 people might touch
a code path, then that code path is going to change constantly,
which means that comment would have to change with the code.
Not everybody who com who refactors that code is going to change
comments. They might not even notice that they're refactoring
something because they might be using a refactoring tool. they
might not even be noticing that they're refactoring something
that has a comment over it somewhere else,
right? And so obviously obviously code is what contributes I
say comments sorry are what contribute the most to code rot is
you have a comment over something that doesn't make any sense
anymore because no refactoring tool actually touches comments
or they rarely touch comments. You can you maybe have refactoring
tools that will do a find replace and find exact text match matches
or something but comments are like the worst place for code rot
to happen. It's actually bad. Commenting is bad. Commenting bad.
Commenting should be avoided unless it's required is how you
should look at it. Comment. This is foo. Then you refactor it
to baz, but the comment still says foo. Exactly. Now, there are
some there are some IDs that will do text replacements, especially
on like function names. They'll do text replacements for you,
but but like relying on that is hard and it can be really annoying.
Touches a bunch of stuff you don't want to touch.
Most modern programming languages are declarative enough that
there you very very rarely need to comment anything. Comments
are helpful for ID annotations. They can be helpful for annotations.
They can be helpful if you have like something complex. Um I
find comments helpful for scaffolding stuff out and then I delete
them after. Sometimes I can forget to delete them. Um and then
hopefully somebody pings that in review and says why is this
comment required?
>> But just the idea that it's a ridiculous practice to
um say self-documenting code is good, self-explaining code is
good. That's goofy as this and the whole cooperation environment.
No, I'd say comments get worse the more the more people work
on something. I'd say maybe comments are more acceptable in your
personal projects. If you have a bunch of teams working on something,
the comments heavy commenting becomes like unacceptable completely.
What's an ID? Ha, good one, Chris. By the way, Chris, I threw
down the gauntlet. I said you're a better programmer than Pirate
Software, just so you know. Hope you're ready to step up because
that was my opinion. I wonder if CJ I coding chie says I refuse
to call him by his full name. We'll read and acknowledge your
comments. Probably not because that would mean admitting he was
wrong. My favorite part was about alarms. Boy, do I wish we could
change the name of them. We can't. Lol.
I don't think that was the only comment on the alarm. The alarms
one I think he was safe on as well. Slap News Network from what
I could see also did not tackle the
Love to see it. I gave him a pass on the alarms. Slap News Network
gave him a pass on the alarms. I feel validated. I feel seen.
I feel heard.
Thank God. Okay. All right. That's it for these logs.
Now, we're going to get into the stuff from today. I think we
saw this before, didn't we? Hold on. Let me Let me pull my docket
here. Yes, we go to this LSF thread. This was the big one today.
This is the big brand new one today. Pirate Software banning
a chatter that stated that one of the ferrets in the rescue died
due to lack of mana. I'm pretty sure this happened back when
the actual WoW stuff happened. Dude, the the ferret passed away.
They're talking about it. It was like, "Oh, he he was he was
couldn't couldn't shield." Okay, he was or some like that. And
Pirate Software did not like that comment at all about needing
to handle it personally. Okay, give me two seconds. I'm going
to hit play on this. I'll be right back again. Just drinking
like liters of water right now. Trying to make it so my voice
is less.
>> Okay, I'll play on this. I'll be right back. Oh, gota
turn it up. >> That one myself. I'm gonna report that one
myself.
>> Yeah, that guy's a piece of
>> Shouldn't have done that on your main. Yeah, that one's
reported to Twitch. One sec. Who got reported?
>> Want to wait to see how long it takes Twitch to ban
this person permanently.
Yeah, I reported already, Jake. Give me a moment. I got reported
for what? We'll find out how long it takes for them to get banned
permanently from Twitch and I'll let you know. Why do people
do this dumb? Yeah, ridiculous.
>> Must be bad then. Yeah, it's just it's just disgusting
hateful behavior and it crosses a line. >> It crosses a
line that uh >> I think is outrageous to be honest with
>> There's like very few things that I would say like cross
a line like go after me, be rude, I don't give a uh what did
they say? They said that Ghost died of
Ah, that's up. gay. That's That's up. That we don't
>> It's very funny. >> Insane behavior, dude. >> That's
very funny. I didn't hit play, by the way. That was >> behavior,
dude. >> Okay. Now, I probably don't have the ability to
really make fun of him or make fun of I probably don't have the
high ground here cuz I have joked about this guy his ferrets
to death. Okay. And the comment is realistically just like several
orders of magnitude more hinged than saying that ferret died
cuz you to death, bro. Use that. Use that fret like a flashlight.
That's crazy. Okay.
So, I I really I can't be mad at the guy who said, "Really?
What leg do I have to stand on there?"
>> So, they're trying to mix the World of Warcraft drama
and say that one of the ferrets that died at our rescue because
she died of a very rare cancer
died of being out of mana because they're a awful human being.
>> It's disgusting.
It's like actually disgusting. So, the thing I would say here
is, okay, it's a ferret, bro. If they said your mom died of because
your mom just died yesterday, that'd probably be bad. Okay, that's
a human being that you had a real relationship with. And this
thing's a ferret. Okay,
let's not pretend that you're like actually dying because your
ferret got made fun of. Let's just let's just dispense with that
entirely. Okay, that's pretty goofy. You're kind of you're kind
of a goof right now. It's not that bad. You'll be okay. You'll
make it. You'll be fine. Hold on a second. I need to reset a
meter.
Okay. Yes, dude. If it's a if it's a person, but also but also
you don't have to get quite that ass mad at people in chat either.
You can just ban them. In fact, I would say probably most of
the time, and I'm bad for this, so I can't really throw the first
stone. Giving them any attention at all is probably a bad idea.
Right. That's it. Oh, true. Actually, hold on. This kind of like
his uh this kind of like his lover dying, right? It might be
a little up. Yeah. Yeah, it was more than just a ferret. You're
right. You're right. This is one of the only ones that can handle
him for more than one spin. Okay. Oh boy. Oh boy. >> So
yeah, they shouldn't be on this >> He shouldn't He shouldn't
be soying out like this just because
just because it will give people something to >> clean
that [__] up like straight up. ghost out of
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, >> You're actually >> Hold on.
But it didn't get posted. You literally could just deny it. Why
did you give this guy attention? He didn't even get it posted.
It actually wasn't going through
at all. It wasn't going through at all. What the garbage? Disgusting.
All right.
>> It's probably a child. Probably >> little much
because of a bad joke. It's not a bad joke. Like they're they're
doing that specifically because it's [__] up, dude.
To mock the death of an animal, especially one that died in such
a horrible way. Like she got a super rare cancer, >> dude.
He's really Oh, he's holding this one dead ferret up. Okay, you
didn't think so, but this ferret, this ferret is actually like
a tower shield right now. Okay, he's holding this far up. >> And
she died within two weeks. And there wasn't anything we would
do. It was awful, man. And to try and use that as a a jab because
you don't like someone on the internet, like you're a awful human
being. There's no real coming back from that either. Like putting
that kind of hate out into the world, like no. That's that is
a a level where you are you are broken as a human being where
you think that that's acceptable. And if anyone thinks that's
acceptable in the community, we'll just remove them because that's
disgusting.
Yeah, this absolutely came out before. I'm surprised.
Why did this clip come up again? Cuz this clip definitely circulated
back then.
I don't I don't actually know why this this isn't a new clip,
but apparently he had another like mini crash out in his Discord
about this. Let's see what the comments are. Dude, does this
Oh, sorry. Does this dude lurker dude zero says, "Does this dude
really just sit for hours with a config file open from his game
that's been in dev for 10 years? Does he actually do anything
with it or is he just posing with it? Lauo, just to set the record
straight, this isn't Heartbound Code, the game that's been in
development for 8 years. That is the config file for his Minecraft
mod. So, that he has also been working on. He doesn't even do
the Java work for it either. Is there any reason why he would
uh why he would do this? Cuz maybe there's some good context
or really
is just that big of a poser and thinks his audience are potatoes.
He sees it as game development, which I can see where he's coming
from. Sure, sure, sure. You could This would be like stuff designers
would do, right? They'd be able to change some things in the
game so they'd be able to see how things perform differently
like balance. People work on on balance and stuff. Sure. Sure.
Sure. Sure.
More comments. The funniest part is how satisfied he gets from
banning someone like he ruined their life or something. Dude,
banning D. This is a stupid comment. This person's
banning somebody is awesome. Banning somebody from the chat always
feels good. Okay. It never feels bad. This is just a ignorant
take. I love banning people. Lol. Shouldn't have done that on
main. Like, what? It's Twitch. I'll just make a new account.
Who cares? Unless you're a streamer, then you have to go your
entire career without being able to type in this guy's chat.
Where's the problem? You know how many mana you you know you
have mana crystals and it shows. Okay, bro. I can't. This is
just another WoW thread. It was weird.
as if someone t as if someone troll posting isn't stoked to get
this level of reaction. They really are. And I often I way way
way too often respond to like this. But it is also funny. That's
the problem. Here's the thing. Hassan,
who many people here hate, they actually
Hassan himself actually has made an entire career off of just
getting one guy by people who are who hate him. He just goes
in on them, right? He'll just always go in on them. As is bad.
He'll But he made a career off of it.
>> Hassan seeks it out. He does seek out the criticism,
guys. Hold on. What is this? I don't even know what this is.
What's the What's the reference? Okay. I don't know. I don't
even know who that streamer is, guys. A group of 4chan. Nothing
gets to me. Oh, yo yo.
Disgusting insane behavior. >> Insane behavior, dude. >> Fake
stretch. Hope it was worth it. It's disgusting insane behavior.
Hope it was worth it. I'm going to report you to Twitch. And
I know people at Twitch so I can get you perma banned from Twitch.
Okay. You will be perma banned from Twitch.
>> Twitch is totally going to ban that person permanently.
Lol. Yeah. Like that's not even that's not even like a crazy
enough comment to get perma banned, right? That's like a goofy
comment. That's just a funny joke. Well, it's a pretty up joke
actually, but depending on how much he loved that ferret, which
is a lot, repeatedly over and over again until it died of internal
bleeding and then he said it had a rare cancer. Twitch is totally
going to ban that person permanently. Yeah, I read that comment.
Just ban him from chat, bro, and move on, bro. Bro, added oo
to the offensive word list. Yeah, dude. These are all This is
all the This is all the people think this is like a new thing.
I remember this exact clip coming out during the WoW drama. I'm
almost positive this is not a new clip. Hold on. Oh, we can't
even go to the Twitch. Yeah, this I don't think this is a new
clip. This is an old clip. What are we doing here, guys? But
maybe that's maybe that'll be what he crashes out about. Hold
on. Let's check it out. Let's check it out. By the way, um thanks
to
over in Chudlogic's Discord who got all these screenshots. Appreciate
you. Appreciate you. Appreciate you.
He grabbed all these screenshots and then I y them directly from
that Discord. Really appreciate it. Thank you. So, he posts the
Reddit thread. They're still at it, eh? Christ, you just sit
in their brains, man. Look at how many insane comments this has.
Oh, we should we sort by controversial. Hold on.
Oh, hold on. Sort by controversial.
Maybe there's some better comments we >> report that one
myself. >> I mean, to be honest, leave the ferrets out
of it. Not their fault their owner is a scumbag. A dead ferret
isn't likely to get offended by a joke. Did nobody say that he's
these ferrets to death? No. Okay. Yeah, that's a valid ban. Meme
about him as much as you want, but mocking an animal dying is
just disgusting behavior. >> Insane behavior, dude. >> I
don't normally give a about down votes, but the fact that I got
negative4 within two minutes of posting, what essentially boils
down to don't mock someone's dead pet is some inhuman ghoul level
[__] guys.
>> I agree that it's inhuman ghoul level. And I agree that
like mocking somebody's pet in most cases is bad. Um, it's probably
bad in this case.
>> 12K from an old clip posted one day ago. The hate this
guy gets is so insane. It actually is insane. It is insane, but
it's actually proximate. That's what you need to understand,
okay? The hate he gets is out of this world. It's insane. It's
incomprehensible to most people, but it is proximate to his behavior.
That's the sad thing. He has acted in a completely insane way
over and over and over again until people like reach Yes. Insane
insane behavior that is insanely insanely justified. All right.
>> Huge. My dad works at Microsoft vibes. Twitch isn't
going to do Mr. Hurt Fifes. The sliver. Holy. You sound like
an angry 12-year-old. Was that one of these? Yeah. This guy right
here. This guy was in here.
Garden it up. Okay. Garden it up. The sliver is going to protect
Pirate Software today.
>> Yeah. Let's make fun of someone's So controversial comments
are all protecting him. O
hopefully the ferret didn't pass away from being gnomed.
it's up joke and it's hilarious. Does Reddit advocate making
fun of pet deaths now? He gets a lot of hate and criticism and
some of it may be warranted. Okay, most of these people are defending.
I see a lot of comments defending him. Good. In what world is
it would it be okay with someone who runs a ferret rescue to
be told a stupid joke about one of his animals dying? I don't
care for pirate one way or another, but anyone who thinks that's
funny needs to check themselves. Okay, one little bit of investigating.
Okay, is this guy posting about pirate software anywhere else?
Hold on. We'll go to submit and see if he's got anything in Pirates
offers subreddit.
>> Nope. Well, New World game. Hold on. Or Binance New
World Game doesn't look like he's ever posted Pirates offers.
So,
>> hey, it seems like he's getting a lot more defense than
you'd expect.
>> Lots of the controversial comments are actually supporting
him. So, huh,
>> that's kind of funny cuz he's he's acting like uh there's
nothing going on. Nobody nobody would support him at all. >> Mr.
Software, we demand that you prove your honor in this internet
argument. Please disclose national government secrets to the
entire world. Is this about him proving that he um is he getting
about proving that he was hired by the government or something?
This isn't that tank game, dude. Seriously. Oh, cuz he worked
he said he was hired by like the FBI or something at some point,
right? That's on the podcast. Oh, that's on like uh JP McDaniels
podcast.
The It Me JP guy. You guys remember the It Me JP thing? Whoa,
whoa, whoa. That guy's Reddit profile could have had a picture
of him. You were trying to dox him. According to Dan, apparently
Dan's just threatening to dox actual people. Hold on. Quick,
quick, pallet cleanser.
Buddy, coincidence. Whenever Willy Whack shows up in my replies,
a bunch of these sub literate low follower accounts created in
2013 flood my mentions who just so happen to be huge fans of
Saltman and his tech startups. Uh,
>> Samuel Colt. Samuel Colt. Samuel Colt reposts all of
Dan stuff. Interesting. Interesting. Huh. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Should we look this up? Should we see if this uh actually exists?
Should we investigate the Dan Saltman gangstalking allegations?
>> Tammy Cole, redact mass, delete your posts. What is
this?
>> Oh, hold on, hold on. Oh, are any of my followers? I'm
in the market for a new place and I'm curious what these condos
look like inside.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Is this guy doxing
Dan? I don't know. I don't even want to show this address on
screen. Is this guy just trying to dox Dan? Dan doesn't live
in a There's no way Dan lives in a condo, but I feel like this
is an implicit threat. If Dan threatened to dox this guy after
this guy's doing implicit threats to him,
>> I don't know.
>> This guy developed some weird fixation with me. A full
Okay. Okay. Okay. Is it about Willy Mack? All right. All right.
Sick helm at Willy Mack show fly as actually should write a character
based on it and turn it into its own thing or something. Could
be some funny
Bruh,
bruh.
Is this going to be all chat GPT comments if this guy replies
to things? Oh, I can't look at his replies. Hold on, hold on,
hold on. Uh,
that was a chat GPT ass comment, wasn't it? Sick helm, Willy
M show. Fly as actually should write a character based on it
and turn it into its own thing or something. Could be some funny
ass. That's 100%.
Really? You guys don't think so, dude? Are there human beings
who type like this? That can't be a human being.
There's no way that could be a human being, is there?
>> Bro, that can't be a human being. No, like like actually
>> actually the less depressing outcome is that this is
a bot account. Please tell me that isn't actually a human being.
>> Bro,
there's no way that's a human
Let me see where. Let me see where he's
>> Someone should just deport Homeman already. From existence,
preferably. Just another evil demonic pruning. Oh, I think it's
a human. Oh, I think it's a
>> I think it's a human. Daliban poster.
Looks like someone wasn't following orders or were up to something
fishy and got popped. What exactly is the point being made again?
I'm confused.
Is this person This is got to be.
>> This has got to be.
Lefties aren't exactly the most clever of folks. Or so it would
appear. There's no actual opinions here, right? What's sad is
how people think sarcastically automatically makes it funny.
Oh, saying sarcastically automatically makes it funny or like
it's somehow an argument appeal to absurdity, I guess. So naive
and annoying it hurts.
>> Dude, are we going to Are we Hold on. Let me
Are we going to ape this guy's entire bit? Cuz I think I think
you'd easily ape the bit right now. Okay. Uh, hold on. You guys
know where this is going, right? Are we doing the thing? There's
no way this is a person. There's no way this is a human being.
Come on. I hate IG. Lol. They don't have They don't have opinions.
Is this supposed to mean? Yeah, I never got the listing, but
apparently blocking removes you from it. Not sure why, but every
time some little plops me on their little list, it pisses me
off right the off. Like, at least call me a slur or something.
Lauo, so silly, bro. Like, that seems like it could almost be
a human. Should we abolish ICE? Yeah, abolish then rebuild with
a new acronym. Too much baggage and too many lifelong bigots
in that field for it to work as intended. Or rather, that's the
vibe I get. Could be wildly off though. Never know, brother.
Is it under the skin OS? It is. Oh, this. Hold on. This is actually
a real opinion. gonna be so insane when this finally drops. Okay,
that's a real post, right? That's like real human interaction
right there that I didn't see before this. Like honestly,
oh, that makes me feel so much better. Oh god. Also depressing
though that there all the other posts. No, no, no, no, no. These
posts are all just like this could easily you could make a way
more convincing Twitter poster with chat GPT. 100%. It's not
even close. It's not even close. This guy has no opinions. He
has no internal monologue. He He basically just like shows up.
This actually could be a Willy Mack alt. He really doesn't understand
or know anything. He like shows up and he's like, "Looks like
something weird's going on here, but I don't really know." Well,
well, well, guys, uh yeah, lefties aren't exactly the most clever
of clever of folks. Or so it would appear.
What's sad is how people think saying sarcastically automatically
makes you funny or like it's somehow an argument. Appeal to absurdity,
I guess. so naive and annoying it hurts. It's just like nothing.
It says nothing. It means
Anyway, if this guy if this is somehow I feel like this is an
implicit threat to Dan this tweet though, somebody said look
at this. Oh, Dan like threatens to dox him or something. But
what is this that the Miami Beach reference happens? Hold on.
I need to I need to pull this up in another thing because if
this guy's menacing Dan, then honestly, you want to you want
to go doxing toe to toe with Dan or some Oh, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Hold on. No, no, no, no, no. Oh, no, no, no. Turnabout
is fair play. Dan must have done it first. Why did this person
This person didn't send me good information. Oh,
hold on. I was linked the wrong thing and I wasn't paying attention.
This guy said, "No, no, no, it's the wrong thing or something."
Oh, I'm going to get off of this, by the way. No more of this.
I need to read more.
>> Hold on. Let me read what this guy said.
>> Oh yeah. Okay. This guy This guy just got it wrong.
The guy who linked me this got it totally wrong. He was basically
like, "Oh, did you see Dan tried to dox this guy?" And I read
the post. I'm like, "Dude, it looks like this guy's like basically
menacing Dan with like listings in Miami Beach or some shit."
Bro, I don't understand why anybody goes to doxing. Just talk
[__] like a normal person.
Just talk [__] Just talk [__] It's so
easy. Why do we got to be unhinged? Maybe one of Dan's properties
could be. Yeah, I don't even want to keep showing this on screen.
But it's like it immediately becomes obvious that that's exactly
what's going on is they're just trying to menace Dan or Yeah,
they're just trying to menace him. Dude, why why do you got to
do that? You ever heard of sketch comedy? You got to keep escalating.
No, thank you. Oh, somebody posting Pirate Software's resume
is LinkedIn.
There you go. Uh, it's astounding how people out there don't
understand how LinkedIn works. Yep. I've always been public about
my work history. Absurd that people think this was some dark
secret. I think this is about him working what? Like security
or something instead of everything else. Hold on. What is the
ordering on this?
I I might have unordered these at the very end. Oh, see this
is where he posts his actual LinkedIn. The point about LinkedIn
is that anyone reviewing your resume blah blah blah blah easier
to make a million call out posts saying I'm a liar. This saying
he's li he lies about his experience. But the the issue is like
your experience hasn't amounted to anything, right? That's the
real problem with pirate software is I don't even doubt that
you've worked at these places. I would just say that's worse.
Actually, it would be better if you're a total charlatan. It
would be better if you were just making it up. It's actually
worse that you worked at these places and picked up so little
that you embarrassed yourself with your lack of knowledge. Right.
That's probably worse.
>> gone far beyond trolling.
>> Sent your connection invite by the way. Legit. I won't
say who I am on uh there, but something instantly lost in an
ocean of weird cuz he's getting harassed on LinkedIn. Guys,
>> I'm laughing but also upset. Not surprised. Not surprising
how or now of all things considered. I hope you find it one day.
Wait, even his LinkedIn is getting Come on, man. Harassing someone
on LinkedIn is like the possibly the most loser coded thing I
can think of. No, the most loser coded thing you should be able
to think of is people who try to use LinkedIn as a dating app.
Okay, that's the most loser I can think of on LinkedIn. All right,
you ever heard of this? People who like try to use LinkedIn as
a dating app or like, oh, look for hot girls who like do this
the same job I do or something. This guy really go through a
second puberty according to him. Yes.
I mean, I'm skeptical, but according to him, yes.
>> Okay. Are we going over to the Candace Owens? Maybe
the Candace
>> Candace stuff. I think that's it for Pirate Software,
by the way. I think that's it up to now. There are some other
videos that are out there. >> I had one other video I think
I linked. Let me see here real quick.
>> Yeah, this video. I think this is just going to be like
an Oh, yeah. This lands a guy. I got linked. I got linked this
and I'm like, "Okay, this is just going to be all the same thing,
right?" Yeah.
>> Or Patchwin. Oh, right, right, right. The Patchwin,
right? The new new thing in Eve, Seven Years of Blizzard,
putting the Mold in Mulavius.
Oh, he copyright struck that guy who made the the Chudlo Logic
game, right? That's funny. Oo, what's this? These the Lyric Wolf
DMs? Yeah, these are the lyric wolf DMs.
Stop games.
>> Do y'all really think this video is over? I could almost
go through the whole stop games thing, but I'm not going to.
I'll move off of Pirate Software. I'll move back on to uh what?
Fentes and Candace Owens. I think that's where we go next.
>> One second.
>> All right.
Okay, let's finish the last half of Candace Owens versus Nick
Fentes. Yeah, let's do it. >> Let's do it. Let's do it.
Let's do it.
>> Where do I download this? Over here. Right. Right. Right.
>> I think we're at an hour. We're like